this is jacquel podcast number 344 with
echo charles and me jacqueline good
evening echo good evening also joining
us tonight dean lister
good evening good evening dean dean
lister from
podcast 137 if you haven't heard that go
listen to it dean is uh
is it safe to say dean's one of the
greatest grapplers of all time is it i
have to have to ask echo charles is it
safe to say that it is safe to say yes
like jiu jitsu world champion
is that accurate
yeah abu dhabi was some it's like the
hardest tournament submission i wanted
three times super fight uh absolutely
and then my division so yeah i don't
know best it's always relative you know
well we could at least at a minimum we
could say he's a good grappler yes sir
it's safe to say he's a good grappler i
agree with that a few good days a few
good days here so uh
good evening dean you know you've fought
in a bunch of stuff hunting uh pride
over in japan fought in ufc and
i thought it'd be cool to bring you on
because we got some stuff to talk about
speaking of the ufc
so
the ufc
kind of changed everything for martial
arts
and and really i guess you go back to
like valet tudo and brazil and nhb in
brazil
but
that type of unrestricted fighting
advanced martial arts
in a decade or two more than it advanced
more than it had advanced
whatever almost in a very long time
but you know i was thinking about that i
was thinking about what you just said
and i actually think that's actually not
true a little bit and here's why i think
it actually brought it back
to reality because if you went back to
ancient greece and looked at pancration
right those guys and you we have
images of people doing pain creation
and they're doing all my plots they're
doing commercials they're doing looks
they're doing heel hooks they're they're
doing what we do and
pain creation if you don't know what it
is it was in the olympics
and i'm talking the old school olympics
i'm talking 648 bc is when pancreation
was introduced into the olympics and it
was a combination of wrestling boxing
kicking joint locks chokes it was in
other words an ancient version of mma
but over time
over time
things got separated the disciplines got
separated
into boxing over here wrestling over
here muay thai over here jiu jitsu over
here judo over here taekwondo over here
karate over here and i was trying to
think about why that happened
and i actually think i have a i have a
suspicion we'll say a hypothesis
my hypothesis is
you know people generally only want to
do what they're good at yeah like oh
you're good at bench press what are we
doing for a workout today we're doing
bench press or oh you you're good at
squats what do you want to do oh we're
going to do squats
oh you're good you're good at grappling
other people
so you know what i don't want you know
i'm good at boxing i don't want dean
lister grabbing hold of me and taking me
to the ground and i don't so i'm gonna
make a different thing something that
i'm good at
and that starts to draw on all the
people that are good at that thing
yeah and over time
it seems like you just have these
separate things now whether that's the
actual reason i don't know
but
everything got
separated
and
martial arts became siloed right whereas
just different sections
and
then unfortunately
martial arts
became
theoretical and it didn't take the much
time for it to go from theory
to lies
and i know lies is a strong word but
if you go look at uh uh
what's the what's the instagram
mcdojo
dojo those are our lies
that that that dude posts what's his
name um
make dojo life so
if you go to mcdojo life you can see
people are teaching lies actual lies to
other people
and you know the lies are things like oh
this one strike
or my chi will prevent me from being
taken down
or i can absorb your strikes with my
aura yeah
do you think that's
you think it's a form of i don't say
hypnosis but like what is it you think
like that is it like oh everyone else is
doing it so i guess i'll do it i'll play
along or is it do they actually there's
act absolutely some kind of
psychological going on there's a
psychological phenomenon that occurs he
isn't he making a movie about this yeah
yeah
[Music]
to explain and i'm sure i'll be in that
movie that's awesome unit too echo
charles uh no okay
so
mcdojo life is making a movie about it
but yeah there's some kind of
psychological
manipulation that happens
where oh
you point your finger at my sternum and
i feel like pain and fall down yeah
and the reason we know it's a lie is
because plenty of people have challenged
like oh try that on me yeah mother
liquor doctor what's the story about you
you were at the i don't know about the
seal base but you were there and
someone's like yeah you know you put
your finger in the collarbone and you're
like no and he's like yeah it works and
you say tried on me and and you double
legged him or something no well i had a
guy saying that like they they had a
name for this like neck
strike and they're like oh if this is
done like if i did this for real
you you'd immediately be like paralyzed
on the right side of your body and that
would cause you to fall down
and then that would lead to my next move
which is a heel stomp to the groin or
whatever right
and so i was like cool do it to me
he's like no and the guy's like well no
it's you know and i was like do it to me
just do it
and it did it obviously it didn't work
like a karate chop to the neck but
didn't you take one second one and the
third one you responded heard that you
were you realized i don't even think i
retaliated the word is that the word no
jeff higgs had a guy
that said that he couldn't be taken down
once he settled his chi
he could root into the ground yes he
would root into the ground and
he the guy's like you would not be able
to take me down and higgs is you know
what do you mean and higgs if you don't
know who he's been on the podcast he's a
black belt jiu jitsu he's a a former
seal and a good friend of all of ours
but this guy was saying oh you can't
take me down once i settle my chi i
always remember that's a good quote
right once i settled my cheek because it
sounds like it might be a legitimate
thing right like that's like you just
didn't make that up that's you you've
told that to other people
and so jeff's like okay well why don't
you go ahead and settle that chi
and the guy goes through his little
ceremonial thing and like
you know gets in the horse stance oh
yeah and higgs is like are you ready
he's like yeah and jeff just like double
legs and slapped him on the ground like
my toes were crossed yeah yeah she
wasn't settled uh so there is some when
you get to that kind of mcdojo stuff
there's definitely some psychological
weirdness that's going on um
but those lies were spread
and you know whether it was you can't
you can't strike through my
aura or the dim mock which is hey if i
touch you here you're going to literally
die you'll try a few a few days later
which also leads to the hey i can't
actually do this to you because i don't
want to kill you and go to jail for
murder okay
i would do it to you because you're
making me mad but i don't want to go to
jail for murder so i'm not going to do
this you know dim mock to you
yeah
and furthermore you know what my the
reason you don't see these moves in
competition because they're not allowed
jaco
as a ufc fighter if i guys come to me
and go hey you know i saw your fight
you're a good fighter you know i'm a
street fighter joe you know i'm like
okay but they had to like qualify that
for some reason to me
i'm like well you know okay that's cool
you know
it's just this is kind of funny that
someone thinks that maybe i've never
been in a real life altercation outside
you know also like
like i i've had my that's why i look
special my face
i've been bit i've been i've been poked
and whatever anything else you can
imagine but it's like um yeah those
things i would call them targets of
opportunity or fighting dirty but you
can't replicate the eye gouge over and
over or you're gonna have everyone's
gonna have one eye you know so so uh i
don't know i just think it's funny that
that people think that
despite all your training
if it's a street fight like you have no
chance
if you could do an experiment where you
took someone and just trained them
in jiu jitsu and they never got in a
street fight
and you went they went against someone
that was a street fighter in the street
it's like it doesn't matter yeah um
yeah
yeah so so
the training will transfer now look
could you pick up some bad habits
where you do something in the street
that
takes now it takes you an extra two
seconds to win because you you should
have done this specific thing because
yeah you could do that but
that's like the tiniest percentage
if there's someone that's like that's
why i don't train you know because i i'm
ready for the street
um
but going back to the storyline a little
bit this these lies which still exist
today
in the 70s and 80s these lies were just
kind of like out of control yeah and
they definitely got picked up in the
military
um
i was looking through some old uh army i
looked through an old army hand-to-hand
manual from 1982 so this is like in the
heyday of chi
and it said this in this manual no judo
you have probably already asked yourself
what about throwing and takedowns like
in judo
we have purposely excluded throws and
takedowns because throws and takedowns
are normally only an intermediate step
to taking your opponent out
after your opponent is thrown to the
ground you will probably still have to
strike him to finish him
so let's just block his attack and
finish him with counter strikes instead
of blocking throwing then striking
it's like
that actually makes you think well you
know it's a good point no you know
that's a good point you know i'm not go
i don't have to take someone down i'll
just take them out
this thing goes on to say that throwing
puts you in a vulnerable position to
throw your opponent you must first grab
him this puts you close to your opponent
and vulnerable to his attack certain
throws yeah certain throws oh for sure
well theoretically again that's the
problem with this stuff is theoretically
especially if i say listen dean
if i you know
double knuckle punch your sternum it's
going to cause you to have a cardiac
arrest so why am i going to bother
throwing you when i can just give you a
literal heart attack
and you would if you were if you said
well why don't you show me that i'd be
like because i don't want to kill you
bro you just have to but trust me
so
actually what's interesting is in that
book that
that field manual is looking at
i you know i'm looking at the rest of it
it has all these like
their foot patterns and it looks like
these dance moves to like avoid and like
strengthen your power and it's just a
bunch of nonsense yeah to be honest with
you but like i just said if this stuff
is getting taught by some authoritarian
figure
and you can't really test it in any way
and you know this is someone that's a
you know a 38 year old
who's talking to an 18 year old recruit
that kind of wants to believe by the way
yeah because most people are like oh
you're giving me a special power i'm
going to take it
i'm not going to question you and that's
probably what leads to some of the uh
weird mcdojo life type
scenarios um
so this to me this is like
the low point of martial arts in history
in my in my opinion yeah this is the
1970s the 1980s and look i get it some
guys were doing the best they could with
what was available and
good on them i know some of those guys
remember dr mick dr mick was one of
those guys and he had a whole crew of
guys like in the 70s they did everything
they could to at the extent that they
could do it
and there was also some guys that were
awesome back then judo jean labelle
like no one can question
the
effectiveness and the efficiency and the
awesomeness of judo jean labelle
50 60s 70s
but as a whole if you look at
commercially
that time period was pretty rough for
martial arts
and then the ufc came
and the ufc brought the truth
and with that
everything changed for the better i'm
taking notes by the way this is good
stuff
everything changed for the better
what's your what's your what's your
notes do you have any so far well i
wrote a few things down i just think
we'll get into this but it's old saying
and i'll butcher it probably but oh
there we go
something like
hard work achieved without
payment or without sacrifice is
something you shouldn't trust
so
the quick way to get this quick knockout
without learning how to box or the quick
way to get the the flying submission or
the steam circle neck break
without learning to grapple you know it
seems good it doesn't work you know um
trying to get in shape without without
working out you know you know you don't
know if you just get like like implants
in your biceps like like you service
yeah
my plants yeah those are going to work
exactly and i'm sorry
i won't say on the internet
it's private um but you know these kind
of things are shortcuts um you know
becoming a millionaire tomorrow without
without even having a business plan you
know this is so i'm saying that's an
interesting idea so it sounds good
and i think if someone trained a lot in
boxing kickboxing and wrestling you know
you could do that stuff if you're
training all these these disciplines
i think it's interesting that is
something that
i think it's imperative to get into
i ask you this jocko it's a it relates
to what we're talking about right now i
had a i had a zoom call with like 12
marine officers they called me it was a
colonel they called me they're all they
were i don't know
captains and lieutenants and they were
talking about you know because they had
fought i guess they saw me compete in
brazil talking about my my training
patterns and
whatever and they were saying how i
could relate to the military and i said
well
and this is something i know i'm
stepping out a little out of my my realm
but i i mentioned something you know
simulation training of course you talk
about that and that's not combat but
that's closer to combat than bang bang
bang you know and uh i know the argument
they don't go through walls they're not
as realistic but you get you get a sting
you got you got hit
and they were like now there's yeah
that's a closer to a gun battle than
laser tag or something like that what
what's the what's this old system that
would that would be yeah there's an old
system called miles gear which is a
laser tag system and they have more
advanced laser systems which are
actually really good now
uh and and yes that's a very those are
great training tools and sure
are there some little things about using
those systems that are not accurate yes
but just as you said it's closer
so if you're getting ready for
i don't even know life in that situation
i i would rather trust the person who
has trained 10 years
in
a struggle where they've dealt with
adversity they've been in they've been
in panic situations they've been calm
versus someone who
i don't know
let's say is open to more dirty things
but has never practiced it in real life
then again if someone has actually been
through life in that situation and used
it that's that's good i guess
but i think it's important to find that
training medium so gloves matter of fact
i guess i should wear more gloves when i
train
but you know if you don't wear gloves
your hands get stronger but you can also
hurt your hands
um so gloves have a place but then again
you can't rely upon big gloves and
boxing you have a small you have no
gloves and you know you can't cover up
the same
so
i think it's important to find the happy
balance that medium between hard
training and realism yeah yeah and
that's what what the ufc did and really
jiu jitsu is a huge part of this is you
can train full speed right you can go
hard and
and look you can spar in boxing
and you can
in wrestling you're you're going live
against other people
but when you take that and put it
together into a martial art jiu-jitsu
was like bringing that forward
and
boxing did it wrestling did it jiu-jitsu
does it muay thai does it but who didn't
do it was like democ and
the old kind of weird traditional
martial arts that didn't actually do
anything
except for a fear except for theory
so
as as the ufc happened we started to see
this in the military and people in the
military started learning and testing
and started to move the
military
combatives to a much better place and
one of the leaders in this a guy named
matt larson i don't actually know him
but uh everybody kind of knows him
he's a former marine former army ranger
and he's
i i think he's pretty much known as the
father of modern army combatives he's
the one that started to train and
formalize
and kind of push this well-rounded
approach
realistic approach
to hand-to-hand
combat
and eventually
his work and look i've given one person
all the credit right now i'm sure he
would
talk about all the people that helped
him get there but um this is the person
that i know of that was involved and i'm
like i said i'm sure there's many more
people but he certainly was a spearhead
on this
and his work
and whoever he was working with at the
time
eventually became
an army field manual an army field
manual 3tac
25.150 combatives
and
i thought today maybe we could take a
look at this manual go through some of
the highlights discuss how it can be
applied and not only can it be applied
to how we fight of course but also how
we train and
how we live
so there you go let's take a look take a
look at this manual combatives
picture of a dude with a freaking k bar
on the cover gotta love that
here's the overview
the overview to kick this thing off it
says combatives training stands apart
from the vast majority of martial arts
training in that producing the
individual's actual fighting ability is
a primary concern
the mental and physical benefits of
training gain their worth from
usefulness in producing more capable
soldiers now
i i'm not 100 sure i agree with that
opening statement only because it says
you know combatives training the the the
main thing about combatives training is
that you're trying to improve the
fighting ability of the person
doesn't all
jujitsu and boxing and muay thai try to
make you a better fighter i'm not i must
be misreading that or something but
that's what we're trying to do is make
someone a better fighter
i guess i'll i'll go with it uh purpose
combatives the art of hand-to-hand
combat bridges the gap between physical
training and tactics
the products of a good physical training
plan strength endurance and flexibility
must be directed toward the mission and
soldiers must be prepared to use
different levels of force in an
environment where the intensity of a
conflict changes quickly many military
operations such as peacekeeping missions
or non-combatant evacuation may restrict
the use of lethal force
combatives training prepares the soldier
to use the appropriate amount of force
for any situation
okay
so that's
that's always good i know sometimes
people ask me have you ever used hand to
hand and they they they actually think
my answer is going to be no
and they think that most people would
never use hand hand but it actually is
very common to use
combative combative techniques in combat
why because you're dealing with
civilians you're dealing with unarmed
people and you can't just run around
shooting everybody
in a semi-permissive
environment or even in a wartime
environment you you see someone that's
not armed or you enter a building
there's a male a female a kid that
doesn't have a weapon
you have to contend with them
so combative is very important
to
have as a skill set to handle
you know actually when the person when
the enemy has a gun that makes
everything easier you kill them you
shoot them done deal
no factor
would you write down dean
a couple of these about the origin of
martial arts and how how some things
have shaped regionally
just a little before but um
also i wasn't mentioned in one detail i
saw someone uh from one military service
of one country
i want them won't get too specific but i
saw the person teaching
uh his head his knuckles right here on
his head hand like he's a boxer with big
gloves if you do that with no gloves
your own hand will cut your face yep
so things like that they're teaching the
recruits i'm talking there's like 200
people in the class it was one of our
services i won't say which one and
teaching people to hold it like this and
i'm saying well
even in boxing i wouldn't do that but
with big gloves it makes more sense you
can see over that right there is someone
who actually has never been punched to
face with with without
gloves on teaching that to 200 people at
a time i'm like i didn't i didn't
correct them yeah i would edit but you
know he's actually he's having them like
this i'm like you know at least want to
be here or maybe just it's just
interesting that that person teaching
people how to punch with no gloves on
probably is every punch in the face and
he may be a skilled boxer
absolutely yeah probably he's probably
may have been punched in the head
you know while he had his while he had
his cover up and you can realize you can
absorb you've got their big glove versus
going into your big glove and it absorbs
you take those big gloves off
you punch right through that person's
hand so that is a little bit we're
looking at a sport boxing which is great
i love boxing but if you do not alter
that part by the way not every box does
this yeah i'm saying this person some
boxes in the corner you covered like
this if you don't alter that rule that
would actually cause you to get a lot of
damage in a fight because this also you
don't cover much of your face with this
well these little hands in the same but
with without gloves so that's an example
i was just trying to say how we're
looking for the happy medium because we
are dealing with the military not boxing
and not wrestling it's actually a
military application yeah
uh it goes on to say here combatives
training includes arduous physical
training that is mentally demanding and
carries over to other military pursuits
this training produces soldiers who
understand controlled aggression and
remain focused while under duress
that's awesome that's true right so when
you get good at fighting it's going to
help you stay calm in other situations
that that's an awesome aspect of
training
it you process the skill the skills
requisite to the mission at levels
in all the spectrum in all the levels of
spectrum of force so you're going to
learn how to control different scenarios
have attributes that make up the warrior
ethos personal courage self-confidence
self-discipline and esprit de corps
that's huge
it's so good for people to know how to
fight it's just so good for people to
know how to fight yeah
you actually
when you know how to fight you become
less arrogant yeah
you might be you might if you're 20
years old you might you might have a
spike in your arrogance right echo
charles you're smiling at that one
yeah there are exceptions we'll just say
that yeah where you get a little spike
in your arrogance but over time you'll
realize okay i'm the reason i'm good is
because i trained more and guess what
there's someone that's trained more than
me and that's the way it is so yeah
generally speaking it'll help your
self-confidence while at the same time
preventing you from becoming arrogant
yeah you get beat up so much you have to
be calm enough
i mean it's humbling man yeah it's
humbling you remember the first time you
tapped me out a hundred times in the gym
when i first showed up i was a young
seal rolling in there thinking i knew
how to fight didn't know jack
choco wouldn't when he would tap you or
just he would just die
so it's humbling
especially what were you 17 or 18 when
we started training 19 19 years old you
were 170 pounds
and i was like 220
i was a grown man you were a kid and i'm
like this poor guy i'm going to smash
his little head
um
throughout modern history attempts to
build successful combative systems have
failed or have been met with limited
success this has happened for several
reasons quite naturally commanders
desire a system that doesn't require any
training time to learn and maintain
so that's a real problem out of the gate
people think well you know i saw an i
saw a thing where you can just learn
four deadly moves and you'll be good to
go why don't we just use that bro what
i'm talking about exactly four deadly
moves to end any street fight
the commander's like hey i think we
should just learn i saw those four
deadly moves why don't we just focus on
those that way you don't have to spend a
bunch of time
there's a guy he actually has it's like
a it's tagged in like youtube so it's
like um x army ranger um plus
10 years of bouncing experiences won
over 500 bar fights never been in the
face once whatever by a system i'm just
like i'm not gonna check it out just
just uh win every fight into three four
seconds just whatever now there's ways
to surprise people there's ways to look
over there and hit someone there's ways
to have your friend and there's all
kinds of tricks uh to trick you and
trick someone out in public but i don't
know just it's just funny how this this
get
a strong quick little snow sacrifice
game or get rich quick like i'm saying
earlier i don't know kind of like um
not the future yep
yep it's it's gonna take some time
uh continue on further training has
often been conducted by experts in
civilian martial arts these experts use
training methodologies that are designed
for more civilian hobbyists than
realities of war that's exactly what you
were just talking about with the boxing
gloves right oh i'm a great boxer it's
out of box cool but i'm not wearing
gloves now i'm breaking my hand now i'm
getting punched in the face when i
thought i was covered up it's like that
there's the issues
often combatives training has been
approached by allowing a soldier versed
in a civilian martial art to use a
limited amount of training time usually
during another course
to teach a useful technique blinded by
their civilian training the trainer
demonstrates what the trainer thinks are
simple effective and easy to learn
techniques selected by based on
situations soldiers may find themselves
on a tactical niche of the specialist
training the trainer teaches the
soldiers these techniques but due to the
limited amount of training time the
soldier quickly forgets them the
soldiers quickly forget them to overcome
these tendencies a combatives training
system must be based on certain
principles and then maintained
so
this was another thing i ran into that
in the skill teams like for a while the
seal teams was using this system where
one of the
one of the cl one of the best benefits
of the system
claimed by the people that were pushing
the system was hey
this system that is we're being taught
only takes five days to learn yeah so
and meanwhile some people are talking
about becoming you know
using more mixed martial arts based
systems when those things take years to
become an expert
why would we do that you know it's sort
of like seven minute abs right it's like
you're like dude i'm not why do all this
cardio weight lifting and diet and all
this stuff i can just do seven minute
abs and i'll be good to go with the app
six minute abs six minutes i'll tell you
oh yeah you outsold me so
so
don't fall for that that that idea that
oh the reason you should use my system
is because it's faster yeah it's not a
good
it's not it's not real
because you're not going to become a
good fighter in five days
could you learn a couple fundamental
moves in five days yes you absolutely
could you absolutely can and they could
save your life yeah you know you could
you could you could your life could be
saved by knowing
some fundamental moves that you learn in
a five day period
but are you gonna be well-versed no are
you gonna forget those moves yes are you
gonna know how to react when there's a
variable involved no
so there is no easy quick solution to be
good at fighting it doesn't exist
could you learn
you know three dynamic moves that if
you're a bouncer in a bar and you're
going against some drunk guy that
doesn't expect it and you do these moves
they'll probably work a lot
but what happens when that dude drops in
and does a double leg on you you know or
squares up and is like a skilled
fighter
it's going to be a problem
so
here's the here's the principles that
they recommend
systematic training foundation
continuous training competition drills
live training integrated training combat
feedback cool what'd you write dude no
i'm just i was gonna say like a kind of
funny story
like we're talking about weight loss but
so you know let's say when i go through
my weight cutting phase you know i'll
lose like 15 pounds in i don't know 10
days and then i'll cut water weight
which is it's really unhealthy but it's
really really bad for you to do that but
you know cut 33 pounds in and you know
12 days whatever you were there with me
on that but so people how you lose that
much weight in two weeks i'm like well
it's not sustainable you know i'd be
honest it's not the secret you could do
that but it's a miserable life it's hard
to do and now you can't do it forever
and remember remember sarge when he
tried to cut 50 pounds in
a week and he had the look of death in
his eye yeah so seriously he lost like
25 pounds right yeah because sarge ryan
stars is a good friend of ours uh
ex seal but he he actually i think was
trying to lose 40 pounds or something
like that yeah he went and look sarge is
about as hard as they come as far as
like just being like i'm gonna finish
this thing whatever it is
he's he's up there in the top echelon of
i'm not gonna give up on this thing and
he's almost walking dead almost walking
dead i mean
he and i i remember i showed up at the
gym
and i saw him and he'd already he was
like
he you know he was done yeah he was like
he was like yeah i was cutting and he
goes he looked at me and look at that
like dead serious look he's like i was
gonna die soon
that was his assessment he was like he
was like yeah he goes i got down he goes
i caught 38 pounds and whatever and he
goes and uh and then i got to a point
where i was going to die soon
and he's a he's a corpsman he's a medic
he's a he's a
independent duty corpsman which is like
the highest level of yeah and you know a
special operation he's a little surgery
yeah so he's just like he's like yeah i
was going to die soon that was a success
so i was trying to tell you the story
about what our bros but it's just funny
it's funny in the sadistic way but even
sarge would laugh at it too he has a
good sense of humor or our type of humor
but uh so there is a way to lose weight
that fast but it's not sustainable it's
not healthy plus you have to know what
you're doing and then you have to know
when to do it correctly and then you
also get in trouble so so weight loss
how about a quick way to lose weight yes
it's possible but it sucks it's
miserable it's not sustainable but you
can actually get on a sensible diet
getting a consistent workout routine and
you know what you could lose let's say
two pounds a week you could do that
consistently you know you can't you can
actually have energy you'll be fine
you'll be hungry but you'll be fine um
but it takes discipline right discipline
so i'm talking to this learning
i see what they're saying it sounds
marketable but
as i was mentioning earlier the quick
fix way to go around things and training
is usually not the best way you're gonna
have to put in the time people yeah
uh and that's exactly what they say here
this next section is called systematic
training learning to fight is a process
not an event
to be effective combatives training must
be part of a system until soldiers learn
techniques that form the system's
foundation they are unprepared for
follow-on training shortcuts are
teaching soldiers what they need to know
is counterproductive
much as advanced tactical training is
counter-productive if a soldier has not
first been taught how to operate his
weapon army combatants training must be
based in a system that both lays a
foundation of abilities that soldiers
take with them wherever they are
assigned and is flexible enough to fit
the wide range of specialized missions
soldiers are asked to do so
it's the same thing that we're talking
about continuous training
combatives training must not end upon
graduation from a training course
for and this is by the way everything
we're saying applies to police officers
as well yeah
unfortunately a lot of a lot of cops
they don't have any more training after
they get out of the car it's horrible or
they get three hours a year or four
hours a year
yeah
so training has to be continuous it
can't end when you graduate for soldiers
to develop their abilities the majority
of training must happen outside of the
institutional training environment so
that's think about that the majority of
training has to be outside what you
learn in the schoolhouse
units must develop their own combatives
programs to spur troops to involvement
encourage commanders to invest resources
so there you go competition competition
is the principal motivational tool used
to spur combatives training competitions
should be not only used to encourage
excellence by giving soldiers a chance
to be unit champions but also to make
the fighting ability an integral part of
soldiering
so if you're not running some
competitions
you're not going to get people to train
and look can you get someone that's like
hey i'm just dedicated i know i might
need it on the job sure
but how many of those 20 year olds that
we're talking about is going to be like
dude are you going to do the are you
going to do the brigade competition see
who's got it
see where you're at
and by the way what about you're doing
the brigade composition so you might
want to like train so you're at least
ready for someone look like a jag ass
uh talks about drills
[Music]
you know you got to do drills live
training live training involves training
against a fully resistant training
partner which approaches the reality of
combat that's what you were talking
about earlier dean there are many
methods of live training each has its
own strengths and weaknesses therefore
leadership combined several approaches
to ensure proper training
integrated training combative
engagements do not happen in a vacuum
they happen as part of a mission so
give soldiers the tools they need to
successfully complete their missions
combatives must be an integral part of
the training so that means
you can't just make it an isolated okay
like you know what a red man suit is
red man suit is like the guy you can
punch because they're wearing like a big
padded outfit
yeah yeah well you need to integrate
that into a random part of a regular
mission a regular training mission you
can't say oh today we're doing
combatives only no you need to walk into
a room and there's got to be some person
in redman's who just ready ready to
throw down and you got to deal with it
and you got to see how it affects
everyone else in the room and how many
people it takes and how it slows down
the assault force and all that stuff
that's integrated training
combat what'd you write down dude
just different things i was just um i
had random stories
i was just saying remember this uh even
people listen this you know yeah yeah
but
the the pretty lie is more appealing
than the ugly truth you know so the only
truth is it's not really ugly if you get
into it you get into the sport it's not
so ugly or maybe that is the beauty of
it in a way
but the pretty lie is always still
appealing i have a 40 i have a 40 course
for you you know you're guaranteed to
win every fight that's still appealing
to most people still is even though
we're seeing this
and
i just hope that people listening to
this
it's not
well it is it can be torturous but it's
something that lights a fire under your
ass your butt every day as far as you
want to train more you i can get sick of
jiu jitsu for one day and next day i'm
fine i'm back into it for some reason
you could say give it like man the next
day you're like okay i want you know i'm
back to it so you can definitely have a
rough day on the bench yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's true it's true
it's just that um
we talk about work repetition drills
competition and stuff it seems like a
lot to do it is a lot to do but
i mean this is the ugly truth you know
what i'm saying so that's why i was
writing down just that the pretty lie is
still appealing to people that are
listening to this right now the pretty
lie is still out there is still result
that people are going to be attempted by
yeah still and and the pretty lie you
want you want it to be true because it's
true you want it to be true that's how
uh get rich quick schemes work right
yeah people want to believe
that a mere 1 299 investment now
when you learn these skills
choco i wanted to believe that you could
lose
18 pounds of water by being in a in a
you know epsom assault time in a half
hour i wanted to believe that it was not
true no quarter pound have you ever
missed weight
no no i was made waiting yeah yeah i was
made wait man you suffered a few times
yeah a big bones i don't know it's not
fun big bones and pizza bro
dude a couple times it was like
all right let's check your weight
oh you're
28 pounds over and you've got to fight
in six days
kenny pizza
how's that pizza tasting i hope it was
good
now you get it paid
uh
combat feedback when soldiers engaged
are engaged in combat they acquire new
information about combatives these
lessons must be captured and analyzed so
the combatives program evolves to fit
the needs of soldiers
through combat feedback the following
lessons have been learned and it goes
through every fight is a grappling fight
of course this does not mean that there
is no striking every fight also involves
striking but always as integral part of
gra as an integral part of grappling
every fight is over weapons control of
this element will most likely determine
the outcome of the fight
there's no shortcut to developing
fighting skill the combat feedback thing
this is something like
even when i was trying to move
naval special warfare more towards
a mixed martial arts
view
and some people would be like
you think you know you you just think it
should be jujitsu and i'm like no
actually i don't just think it should be
jujitsu at all
and in fact and this was the most
important thing i tried to say was it
shouldn't be closed it shouldn't be a
close it shouldn't even be a quote
system
it should be
an open learning continuous learning
evolving thing that we're always getting
better at
and that way there's things that work
and they work now and maybe if in the
future we have a different type of body
armor that is more dynamic or it takes
up more space or it's heavier or light
or whatever like things are going to
change
or the way you sling your weapon now or
a different radio you got to carry with
that that causes something or a helmet
like there's all kinds of things you got
to make adjustments to you grapple with
plates on your body with plates oh yeah
because the plates get really they get
really in the way let's say
yeah
and there's different things that yeah
there's certain things that might not be
optimum with plates yeah and so okay
what adjustments are you gonna make
and maybe a new set of body armor comes
out like you could put something called
side zappy plates in which now you have
plates on your side and how does that
inhibit your movement you'll find this
ridiculous jockey on the plane with the
front plate and the back plate and
that's a belt on with uh with you know
whatever yeah just just stuff on the
belt and uh i set up and guard and
and i i had a little i was a little bit
a little heavier back then and the front
plate pinched my uh with the belt and
you tapped out
come on i can't set up a guard the same
way
[Music]
you're training in should evolve and
look it's beautiful to see right now
jiu-jitsu evolving like crazy and it's
kind of evolving exponentially
i think jiu jitsu is evolving
exponentially now
because every
one move leads let's just say
theoretically every one move leads to
two moves
would you say that's something you could
say a claim it should i should maybe
even one move it could be that one move
leads to four moves and some one moves
lead to seven moves but let's just say
in general conservatively every one move
leads to move sure so there's been so
many new moves created in the last 10
years
and they've all created and spawned more
moves and more moves and more moves so
it's a
highly evolving sport
yeah absolutely and some things that
some things have been forgotten or
reinvented again
for sure
um
someone's done a lot of things before
some things have been forgotten some
things are out of style but some things
are definitely being invented right now
all right then
this is a really thorough manual and
this is what the army does man the army
doesn't play around they leave no room
for interpretation and stuff they got
things on safety they got the things on
risk asses assessments on how you're
going to keep everybody safe while
you're doing it
one thing they say is combatives
training has inherent risks these risks
may not be readily apparent and are
sometimes counterintuitive to the
untrained person therefore a competitive
instructor certified at the appropriate
level should be involved in the process
to mitigate these risks
and it's also important
as a trainer to be able to point out the
risks of not training like if you don't
train because listen if you train you
can sprain your ankle yeah if you train
you can you hurt your shoulder but if
you don't train
what's the risk there the risk is you
can
yeah it's it's going to end up being
worse
so
they go through uh you know how to set
up a training area what's general safety
precautions to to make and then they got
this thing
this is interesting
according to a report published by the
armed forces health surveillance center
730 individuals who served in an active
or reserve component in the army navy
air force or marine corps were
hospitalized or medically evacuated for
injuries and current incurred while
performing wrestling judo and unarmed
combat training between january 2002 and
december
2009 this averages to roughly 100
personnel per year during an eight-year
period
now quite frankly that's not that bad
i think that's actually pretty darn good
to go considering how many people are
actually training
it says it should be noted that 194
personnel 40 of those hospitalized and
26.6 of all injuries were injured while
off-duty or have unknown duty status
unsupervised execution of combatives
techniques is strongly discouraged this
also means some of that percentage is i
got a bar fight
and i went to my
my my gunny serge and said hey gunny i
was training combatives and i broke my
hand on you know my training partner's
face
well how's your oh you know how's your
buddy oh he's okay but you know i need
to get my a cast
so there's some of that going on
um
areas of the body most commonly injured
of the injuries documented in the study
a large percentage of 45.6 percent
occurred in the lower extremities
in fact fractures primarily of the ankle
tibia or fibula
[Music]
accounted for nearly one half of the
injuries
that seemed high to me and you know what
it shows you they're doing a lot of
takedowns yeah they're doing a lot of
takeouts but isn't it weird also
fractures
they're talking about fractures
and so so fracture's percentage was 50
sprains and strains was only 13 and what
i thought to myself is that's because
you know what you don't have to go to
the hospital for a sprain or a strain so
you're not reporting it i mean how many
how many times have you hurt your ankle
or your knee training
a few times kickboxing a few times and
and gone and not gone to the hospital
many times i mean it's like ridiculous
right how many times did i go home like
oh i'm kind of limping a little bit you
know my shoulders tweaked my elbow got
straightened out dean lister um whatever
so i think a lot of the strength i think
sprains and strains is actually you're
gonna get it it's like almost 100 yeah
yeah but people just kind of like oh
just put ice on it and call it good well
you think maybe that that the these
lower extremities injuries is from like
kicking well i don't know
my goodness
i think it's take downs take those
straight up fractures i mean yeah i
guess
you know how maybe they'll turn the
wrong way you know a good wrestler face
with hips yeah i'm saying like when
someone's learning you're going through
those those rough areas were more likely
to get hurt you know yeah
yeah actually if you think about how
many broken bones
have you seen on the mats during
training
not many yeah no it's usually i think
i've seen two
i think i've seen two
one like
ankle and one uh
the radial yeah yeah guy got caught and
uh my buddy got caught
bicep slicer oh yeah and i heard it
crack
spiral fracture
and he was in the damn
stone on deployment damn but
but yeah that's why it's weird but how
many people how many times have you seen
somebody get
a sprained ankle a sprained knee that's
like you can't count them all so this is
a weird thing
this is a weird thing
and then it goes on to dislocations and
skull or bone fractures and other
intercranial injuries other injuries
concussions concussions they've only got
at three percent chuckle how many people
get hurt on the obstacle course
no saying on the obstacle course uh
probably not a ton but how many people
get hurt going through land warfare
training out in the desert oh you know
any kind of training yeah people are
gonna get hurt like what in land warfare
training like
twisted ankle running hurt knee
um he's usually an ankle and you're a
back right
picking up my buddy
kind of especially when some people were
running man warfare
and there was a lot of buddy carrying to
be done sorry fellas uh just trying to
be ready for war
but
yeah people are going to get injured
here's another one like fast roping or
parachuting like people break their
ankle people land wrong people get hurt
so yeah you're doing high-risk training
people are going to get hurt
um traumatic brain injury
the armed forces health surveillance
center
study concluded that a relatively small
percentage of 15.5
of combatives related injuries occur in
the head back neck and nervous system
dude i don't think
15 is a small number i don't like that
number however these injuries can have
disastrous consequences which can
include traumatic brain injuries that's
why you got a spar you can't spar every
day you know
boxing yeah every day oh yeah and for
sure that's something that we've learned
and you and i had did not learn
um until it was too late because we
already probably sparred hundreds of
rounds back in the day live with mma
gloves by the way yeah which is not
smart
you can see better you know
i mean
yeah
that's kind of disturbing yeah you know
when you think about all the rounds you
did
back in the day
while training for camp
is a lot of you getting punched in the
head do you spar em with mma gloves just
striking or is it a full both yeah take
downs but um but you know you put
vaseline on anything or or you put a you
wear headgear and small gloves or big
gloves and no headgear yeah it depends
but that's my that you know we kind of
evolved yeah and now it's evolved like i
spar a lot less
a lot less wasn't it back in the back
when you were going through seal
training they put the boats on your head
and jump on the boats yeah but now they
don't do that they don't do that anymore
you have a seat you learn from the past
because everyone has bad necks higgs you
paws yeah everyone right sarge yeah
yeah
yeah that was not healthy you got a boat
on your head and the freaking 220 pound
instructor jumps into the boat they put
sand and it's not like that
moment of impact the
weight is distributed evenly amongst the
six or seven heads in there no he lands
wherever he lands
and it takes at least you know
yeah that was not good and it feels like
there's no real benefit in that kind of
quote-unquote training
there's there is no benefit it's only a
negative it's kind of like getting
punched in the head yeah yeah that's
what it was
now listen you have to get punched a
little bit yeah so that you are used to
and you're not scared of it but
you don't get better at getting punched
in the head that's why we don't line
people on walls and just start going ham
on their faces those videos with guys
line up on the wall start just punching
yeah that's the smartest way freaking
different tactics that's not just
different tactics that's like
freaking jerks
uh
traumatic brain injury occurs when a
sudden trauma or head injury disrupts
the function of the brain
initiating the onset or worsening of the
following symptoms loss of or decreased
level of consciousness loss of memory
for events immediately after altercase
alteration and mental state
confusion disorientation
neurological deficits
weakness loss of balance changing vision
so so
you get a lot of these things if you're
sparring all the time and you shouldn't
so
don't
um
and it goes on to some more of this
danger
should a soldier exhibit any symptoms of
traumatic brain injury soldiers should
ask should seek immediate emergency
evaluation this is how i mean remember
when i got a really bad concussion from
you that's it you've had like i don't
know three or four yeah but there was
the worst one where i went actually had
to go to the hospital yeah
yeah and i remember
the doctor said hey you know you no
contact for
i think she said six months what
happened which one was that
you had on my knee or something no uh
i wasn't my shot and you looked at me it
was a head it was your head
my head and your chin my head your chin
yeah okay yep and it it
it didn't knock me out knocked me down
and then i was remembering i was looking
up at the roof and yeah like i saw the
word like the
i was like why is dean rotating me right
now
like i'm looking up at the rafters and
city boxing remember the city boxing at
those big rafters and i'm looking at
them and they're turning and i'm like
i'm trying to put my feet to stop you
from turning me but it wasn't turning i
was turning you back yeah i know you
weren't
and uh then i woke up in the middle of
night was throwing up and dizzying to
the bathroom and so i went to the
hospital because that boxer had just
died that's right yeah a boxer had just
died and i was like bro i'm messed up
and uh one of my team guy friends came
and drove me to the hospital because i
couldn't like i was done
and but here's the
here's done now here's dumb she's like
no contact for six months and i was like
cool four weeks later i was like i think
i'm good to go yeah yeah
and i was we were training again like
doing that so don't be stupid did you
get amnesia or anything like that no
no no i didn't
i got a concussion from football i think
i told you this where i got amnesia
straight up woke up like not well i was
conscious but i woke up you know you
come to the amnesia or whatever just
confused same deal no contact but they
were like well that's your first
concussion
the next week
i played a game the first hit i took
another amnesia scenario yeah like i
don't know where i am or whatever that's
why they have concussion protocol now
and all this stuff yeah they didn't used
to have that back in the day when you
were over there at uh kauai high yeah i
had probably about 10 serious ones but
one of them after japan i fought arona
i went to spain like afterwards and and
i was like a 12 year old kid like them i
had the i had the mental capacity of
about a 12 year old kid i was just like
hey yeah and i would just do i would
just i was very
i don't know for about two weeks yeah
yeah
did you you felt out of it or was it you
know yeah i'm standing well i'm going to
fall down catch myself
you know sometimes twice a day sometimes
twice a week and then went down even
like six months later i got like one or
two of those like like oh i got to sit
down but not for a long time you're just
like playing legos and stuff
damn it chocolate come on that's a good
time well time but right they're like
hey uh how long six months or whatever
because yeah you feel better because
even the next week i felt better i was
like i'm not dizzy i don't feel no pain
or whatever but like your head is so
weak now yeah so like you could get like
a small light i got a light hit it was a
lightning and i was just confused like i
don't even know where i am because they
pull you out of the game then oh yeah
because you were just done everyone on
the whole team like knew i'm like
brad it's kind of scary to be honest
with you like you don't know what's
going on at all and oh yeah they knew
because i had it the week before it
pulled me out yeah well dean you've
taken some shots
in your mma career yeah like and you've
never been knocked out
in an mma fight knocked down i've been
knocked out you've been knocked down but
you've never been knocked out but
i've watched some of your fights that i
was actually at
and i still can't believe that you
didn't get
k owed to next month he was like oh cool
whatever i'm going to keep fighting you
this reason i don't look like justin
bieber
i look a little bit different for some
reason
all right um let's be careful of
traumatic brain injury chokes next
section on chokes chokes are the most
effective way to end a fight without a
weapon they incapacitate an enemy with
supervision chokes can be applied in
training exactly as a soldier would on
the battlefield yeah
great
for training purposes hold chokes only
until your opponent taps holding a choke
for lengthy periods may cause injury or
death okay so yeah this is one of the
one of the things we're dealing with
they have to say that they have to say
that um i know that's wait how does it
say what like it could be injury i mean
if you hold some sleep for five minutes
yeah um
but if someone goes to sleep
you let them go they'll wake up now if
someone is there's certain uh substances
that can actually interact with with
certain organs that could be dangerous
that's true if someone has a medical
condition never know
um
but it's uh i i swear being choked out
is safer than being knocked out oh it's
not it's it's infinitely safer it's
infinitely safer now if you choked out
is
it painless i would get i would go so
far as to say
being choked out
has no negative impact on your health
yeah no now look would you want to get
choked out all day every day no but
if you get choked out
30 seconds later you are totally viable
to do anything that you
well that you could need to do yeah with
no impairment whatsoever you get knocked
out just like you said echo charles if
you see if someone gets knocked out it's
grounded you are messed up yeah and you
have probably some kind of permanent
damage to your brain
choked out no factors
would you compare being choked out to
like your leg falling asleep
i'm sure anatomically and
physiologically there's a lot different
but yeah probably something you know
like you're like policy you're like oh
yeah and then it comes back yeah
whatever right yeah then you're fine
that's what it feels like to be honest
yeah it's just it's it's horrible
because you know law enforcement
actually at this point there's so many
law enforcement
departments where
the choke is
illegal yeah it's the same is same as
shooting someone else yep it's a lethal
force and you will be charged
and
when properly trained now look if
someone's improperly trained
yeah there's a higher percentage that
they might actually hurt somebody true
yeah
but anyone that's properly trained i
mean please if you come to arrest me and
i'm being a jerk because i'm on drugs or
drunk or whatever choke me out please
choke me don't shoot me don't shoot me
and don't beat me in the head with a
baton right yeah because that's gonna
mess me up permanently whereas you
choked me out you put me to sleep put me
in cops i'll wake up sober up and i'll
be like i'm sorry man
whereas
if you hit me in the head with a baton
six times which is what it's gonna take
to knock me out i'm gonna wake up
i'm gonna be messed up i'm gonna have
cuts all over my head stitches stitches
brain damage of some kind
i'm gonna sue everybody
i'm gonna be it's just a disaster yeah
where's he put me to sleep nice little
99 rear naked choke yeah
it's a terrible thing it's a terrible
thing that that's been um demonized the
way it has
and and look there's been some cases
where clearly it was a freaking major
problem because a chokehold got put on
held for too long put on
by someone that was panicked or
otherwise freaking out yeah
and
it was the wrong move to make and the
training wasn't there to let a person
realize oh this person's unconscious now
i need to let him go yeah
true and no one was detached enough to
be like hey
you that person's subdued now you can
let them go
but that's jokes
what'd you write down dude
no i was just i was saying like um you
know
about the illusions of
well i mean it's it's ufc you know so if
you if you have any choke i'll i'll bite
your arm or i'll poke your eyes and
truth is you get a high level black belt
and they have a choking try to actually
start start with my arm in your in your
mouth if you want your your teeth will
it won't shatter but you you'll you will
you will stop biting me oh you reject my
eyes you have three seconds to go to
sleep i could hide mys2 and eyes are not
like jello i mean they're very sensitive
but
i mean it's just funny people think oh
you know if if that's ufc they're going
to try to just reach back his eyes
that's annoying it pissed me off
actually you saw that video with boss
ruden yeah you know with the show called
reach back from my eyes and it's or
reach for the groin yeah so these are
targets or opportunity you have to
include that as a possibility right
right but i'm saying like um just the
thought of here's a quick ease we have
to choke just reach out for the eyes no
it's not that easy because if they know
what they're doing they're squeezing
your three seconds yeah you're sleeping
yeah you're sleeping and you're not
getting their eyes out in three seconds
you might scratch your eyelid yep it's
i've had people try to gauge my eyes out
before and it's ineffective compared to
a choke they're going to sleep yeah
it'll kind of piss me off and i choke
you choke harder yeah bite my arm right
through your teeth you know it's just
stuff like that it sounds brutal it is
brutal but don't don't bite my arm you
know what i'm saying so yeah so that
kind of stuff there's a happy medium of
including that as a possibility but not
realizing that that is a quick fix it's
just something to include the training
uh joint locks attacks on most large
joints for example elder elbow shoulder
and knee are painful long before causing
injuries which allows
soldiers to conduct full force training
without significant risk of injury the
exceptions are wrist attacks
and twisting knee attacks
therefore these attacks should be taught
with great care
and should not be allowed during
sparring
that's interesting pete the greek
disagrees 100 percent yes
the way we do giaco echo myself
what they're talking about is something
known as a toad or a heel hook it twists
your
your heel or your foot but the
consequences of your knee twist usually
depends on you if you have a strong and
a weak ankle your ankle might pop first
now these kind of things done
responsibly can be done in training as
long as you catch and release also your
partner has to know not turn the wrong
way and hurt themselves so i think they
should be included in training but i see
a white belt you don't teach them a
healer can go hard because yeah there's
a with a boot on a military boot you can
just grab the boot twister you don't
need to get you look you know they can
just grab your boot so so with the boots
on
like lock city bro yeah
it is it is
with heel hooks heel hooks do not hurt
until they pop until you're injured
right at the edge yeah right at the edge
they might fertile but i i've i actually
hurt someone
uh with a heel hook i was a blue belt
and i was training with a friend of mine
who's a seal who's all amped up
and i put a heel hook on and i i did i i
put it on to a point where i was like oh
you know
whatever he he's not tapping and i think
i just like let it go or whatever but it
hurt him
so
and he didn't really feel the pain from
it i went to something else so
it is a thing and you do need to pay
attention to that that
heel hooks really don't hurt that much
until you're injured
um
wrist locks
yeah there's also some weird i don't
know why
is that because there's many bones in
the you know the hand is always bones
together and uh there's
a certain little pop could be this one
bone in this one this one little like
ass doctor luke would have he knows over
the hands human hand obviously but it
could be this little knuckle it could be
the finger it could be you get me this
it could be that finger could be so a
little pressure could pop a finger yeah
so so that's what they mean they are
effective though there's some really
effective wrist locks um generally
speaking on the ground there's not a lot
of very effective standing wrist locks
against the train opponent at least
because there's because the opponent has
a lot of mobility yes yes you need to
isolate one of the major limbs the neck
or one of the arms to control next to
the trunk of the body is what i'm saying
yeah you know how like the
heel hook right you don't really feel it
until like kind of too late scenario
right what about knee bars in your
sparring same deal kimura is worse than
a straight knee lock
the pain to twisting the twisting motion
if you keep if you're on bob's in a
chemo it could be a problem if your knee
pops from a straight i mean you know
you'll be sore now if you if you don't
tap at all and it does break and then
it's of course serious injury but the
straightening lock you feel the pain
right away but your question about the
pain level yeah exactly right pain level
in a straight knee lock is there yeah
you'll notice tap yes
i've had my knee pop from the knee bar
didn't feel it even when it popped i
didn't really feel it that my i knew
there was something wrong you're so
athletic seriously running your whole
life maybe that's the reason running
around and running you lose a lot of the
nerves in your knee yeah it's very
possible yes because it did swell up i
didn't like
it was it actually injured though it was
like because you have those weird knees
too that sometimes make a noise for no
reason they pop out right
um yeah and that's a good point it
probably was that if they were swollen
for i don't know a week two weeks maybe
which actually technically as far as
compared to a real knee injury is not
that much time i know so was i injured
moderately injured but it did swell up
and i think it was just a meniscus
situation but i didn't feel it though
it wasn't painful strange so yeah
like absolutely
then that next day their arm swallow
yeah but the knee is a little more
serious but it's not as bad as a kimura
kimura if you get an injury from kimura
it's a little worse than a straight knee
walk generally twisting you look is
different yeah well your shoulders have
completely more complex joint twisting
what have you you got knee surgeries
pretty early
yeah didn't you dean lister 97 and 2000
i must have been 20 21 and what was the
first injury
it was it was from high school football
i got hit from the side my knee was on
someone was on their like they already
got knocked down they were on their
hands and knees and my my knee got
propped up against the ribs i didn't see
him i'm pursuing the online i was a
linebacker and uh someone hit the right
side and just i twisted over just
perfect you know i didn't see the guy i
saw the video my knee planted on the
side and i got hit for the right it just
just popped right over so was it fully
acl oh ac acl the lcl and the uh
meniscus medial media
so you got that triple threat right
bucket handle terry that's what they
call it
but uh yeah uh and then the doctor's
like you need surgery but you you have a
strong knee capsule like what does that
mean well right now you're okay kind of
but that eventually just came out james
nielsen you had a triangle i was in a
full squat just came out one time on the
mat in 97 and then i got surgery and
then you needed surgery i always
kind of forgot that you got surgery in
97. and that you most of your career was
post and
shout out to ron burgum for i had an
employment for them and my insurance
collapsed just like a week after that so
i had full
so i got yeah thanks to ron berger my
friend yeah he took him the job
you got lucky on that one that's an
expensive thing
yeah and then you got another one in
yeah but that was just a meniscus that's
just a shaving you know meniscus 2001
2003 is what it was a good year for me
in brazil 2001 i was you know for three
weeks
not a big deal and then you got soul
shoulder surgery total surgery i had i
had five shoulder surgeries in in a year
and a half yeah
that's not fun because i had an
infection in brazil in that basil i have
an infection you know a really bad
serious infection like they were even
saying in portuguese like hey we're not
saying you might get your armor cut off
but you know it could happen i'm like
bro when a doctor says
they're kind of like but they're telling
you for a reason so yeah so about
thinking what surgery was that like the
original problem what was it it was my
medial my
my
infraspinatus my subscapularis and my
labrium and my rotator cuff which was
all ripped up from all the competitions
i've had also in russia broke broken
russia
snapped
bad arm that's all but it's okay right
surgery is happening yeah we have a lot
of overlapping surge or injuries even
actually i didn't um i tore my knee kind
of real similar in a similar way yeah
the year before 96 you know football
same deal and then your right bicep too
yeah the bicep in fact one of our
surgeries
was on the same day we ran into each
other did you know that yeah
i go in for the surgery and the doctor's
like oh yeah dean's here i was like what
and then he's like coming to after his
surgeries like wait who was the doctor
where he like do you guys well yeah
because you said when i first um
tore my bicep was after you tore yours
it was at a different time so when i
tore mine i was like hey who's your guy
like who did you go to because he was
back in the game so i was like let me go
to that guy so it was norman kane yeah
and so i went to him and then um then he
patched me up and said dean's here
no no that was the first one the second
or the when i ran into him was the
second one
what if i'm being ruled out i'm like
echo don't do it don't trust him
i wouldn't trust him before i was you
know throwing one bicep haven't you dean
oh well yeah just it was a complete
complete tear though just rolled with my
shoulder you were there when they rolled
the shoulders right through your
shoulders yeah no biceps
robert garcia was like oh
i don't know yeah that's battery tree
yeah but the second one it was like nine
years later when you got your other
surgery on your shoulder bicep it was
like you had a big surgery
so i went and norman kane did yours
right that one yeah but i didn't get it
from norman king didn't do my name was
the other guy it was like his partner
guy or whatever so but i saw that's who
told me when i walked in it was norman
kane and he was like oh what's up man uh
dean's here
and then he's like no we finished
already and then june's like you know
when you come
that's a bad sign for jiu jitsu when you
let go to get surgery and your other
friends are in they're getting surgeries
there too yeah
but 100 percent is your um how is your
it's getting stronger
rehab in progress you know so i'll be
okay yeah um
yeah check
it actually has a protocol like i said
the army doesn't miss anything protocol
for injured soldiers you know it's got
everything in here it also says that
striking is not the most efficient way
to incapacitate an enemy and often
results in injury to the striker
so this is like a pro grappling
statement not only is it not the most
efficient way but i'm probably going to
get a hurt too
because the old school boxers apparently
no gloves would punch the body more yeah
that's why the hands were down here
because punching the forehead back in
those days
your hand's broken now you're like you
know probably to retire now or you know
you're not you're not going to go to the
job at the factory now right and these
guys actually worked at the time so the
rumor actually i remember i'm pretty
much known with the 1800s it was like
the hands were low because you were
punching more of the body the face yeah
but but you're taking a chance to fit
yeah so there we go i mean they knew
back and then they didn't have the same
medical care we do now and there's a
reason they were hands low
yeah that's they actually keep them in
tucked to their sides a little bit
prevent those body shots and yet further
out in front of them so they maybe can
get up and like defend the face a little
bit if they need to that's interesting
uh
it does say however striking is
important part of overall fight strategy
strikes can be very effective in
manipulating the opponent into
unfavorable positions striking be
practiced with various types of
protective padding such as gloves
defense can be practiced using reduced
force blows so there you go
it talks about like i mean this is such
a detailed
document and the army just does this man
the army is squared away when it comes
to doctrine they make them
just incredibly detailed things and
this team obviously put a huge amount
into this
talking about training
the military profession is inherently
dangerous commanders must train their
units to tough standards under the most
realistic conditions possible
this chapter discusses the combatives
training program from an institutional
training to
operational unit training training areas
training techniques teaching techniques
and safety precautions that must be
considered before conducting combatives
training and they just go
they go they get after it in this thing
i mean this is like
if you didn't know anything
about anything you could pick up this
manual and start a piece together you
know
a deliberate work risk assessment
worksheet
is vital to identify a necessary risk by
comparing potential benefit to potential
loss the draw process allows us to
identify and control hazards conserve
combat power and resources and complete
the mission this process is cyclic and
continuous it must be integrated into
all phases of
operations and training like these guys
are just they're not even playing around
with this
and then they go what do you got dean no
just saying like i like how this is
structured i really like it a lot
because you need to have a guideline
especially in the military i think it's
really good i think you're doing a good
job so far folks are very complete
one thing that i think is very important
as far as training on your own if you're
in the military or
if you're under some certain guidance
like this is there has to be some wiggle
room some leeway such as
also a move that i don't even do that
well but i know my students do well like
uh like
remember eric had a better darts than me
maybe i taught it to him though um so so
there's certain things i'll teach that
would not be under my guideline but i
teach because some people do those moves
naturally well some people i wouldn't
strive i wouldn't teach i'll teach in
the triangle but let's say the eggs are
not very long it's not going to be their
main move but they end up learning
anyways someone else is going to is
going to be that's going to be their
move so i think it's really important we
have the guideline but there's also has
to be some wiggle room so that's why
it's important to train in your own your
own free time to find your own style i
think it's really important for jiu
jitsu yeah you don't want to learn by
the book only it's good to have
guidelines yeah it's got to have the
guidelines but you got to get out there
and then it goes through the whole thing
of like how the basic combatives course
of instruction there's a bcc instruction
and what that does and what that's what
that includes and then tactical
combatives course and what that's all
about and what that includes and then
you get them combatives master trainer
course of instruction
the cmtc
this addresses all ranges of the fight
by training striking skills and
introducing soldiers to the integrated
integrating combatives training into the
rest of their warrior tasks and drills
i.e incorporating combatives into
training close quarters combat training
and mission unit training
and then it goes over duties of the
combatives master trainer course
certified instructors
that and it says everything that they
have to do and there's a whole list of
things that they have to do
to be uh like a master trainer in this
stuff
just they went to great
lengths to get this program and and you
know a lot of this i bet was
they they
you got to play the game in the military
you know you got to play the game you
got to give the leadership what it is
that they need to say yeah we yep
oh this is i bet you they pulled out
like some
immediate action drill rifle training
guidebook and said all right we're gonna
put all the stuff that's in here about
safety we're gonna put it in here yeah
and they did an awesome job
of setting this up where it's kind of
hard hard for the leadership to say well
you guys really haven't thought this
through it's like oh no we thought this
through to the freaking nth degree
yeah
here's some of the stuff the
the uh combatives and structure
instructor has to do receive at least 20
hours of instruction gain the ability to
teach basic combatants and develop
scenario-based training and understand
standard competition rules
pass a hands-on performance oriented
test on basic competitive combatives
techniques including the following
maneuvers escape the mount trap and roll
past the guard achieve mount from side
control arm push and roll to the rear
mount escape rear mount escape the mount
shrimp to the guard scissor sweep rear
naked choke cross collar choke from the
mounted guard bent arm bar straight arm
bar from the guard straight armbar from
the
mount
sweep and attempt the straight arm sweep
from the attempted straight arm bar
close the gap and achieve the clinch
take down from the front to the mount
rear knit rear take down front
guillotine choke
[Music]
pass a written exam on the combatives
program and standard combatives rules
conduct at least one scenario based
training exercise
and receive an additional 20 hours
training so they they've got everything
like that's what you need to do
right so that's
they're this is as thorough as you could
hope for they forgot the spinning
jumping double reverse inverted upside
down um
but other than that and you know we had
tim kennedy on and he was talking about
he's the three-time
the three-time
army combatives champion
uh and when he went he won it twice and
he was the only person that had won it
twice and then he wanted three times so
but but that's just an awesome
competition it's grueling what they do
it's like multiple fights and the rules
kind of escalate as you go through i
think like the first day when they're
just trying to weed people out just like
grappling only yeah
and then the next day is like grappling
with
strikes on the ground or something like
this and then like the finals is just
basically mma with freaking fatigues on
right
that's freaking legit man
and there's everybody shows up to that
thing it's the army right
freaking legit
outstanding way to figure out where
people are at
and then it gets into
like
unit training
and a successful unit combatives program
continue to focus on the core techniques
taught to soldiers during their initial
military training mastery of these moves
not exposed to a large number of
techniques will result in more
proficient fighters
for unit combatants training to be
successful it must become an integral
part of the unit's culture successful
unit combatives programs have four
characteristics training for every
soldier set standards and hold people
accountable for them motivate soldiers
and leaders to achieve excellence
integrate combatives into mission
training so i i think like that's the
kind of thing that statement right there
this is what law enforcement needs to
look at
yeah combatives training for everyone
they need to do it all the time it needs
to be part of mission training and you
know i've been going around saying for
the last couple of years that i think
law enforcement should be training 20 of
their time
20 of the time that you're at work as
law enforcement you should be getting
trained
but i think it's interesting because
jaco
uh we talked about this personally about
law enforcement you're like you've done
vehicle interdiction you know you've
actually done it in wartime scenarios at
night you know and the thing is
um i'd rather get arrested by draco than
actually no
other people would prefer to get
arrested by chocolate than someone else
who didn't know jiu-jitsu so the thing
is
yeah it's not always nice with me you
know i'm almost i'm also not that nice
back by the way so to be fair but i
think it's gonna be you know is that
extreme i think the idea of
you know
human confrontation just being used that
more and more i mean i mean how do you
get debate skills without getting into
you're not getting an argument not for
an argument you actually have to get
into the debate itself you can just talk
by yourself or get in the debate with
someone else to get skills like that you
know so i think it's a good good point
plus you get in shape
yeah so so let me ask you this question
picture you have
[Music]
10 police officers yeah
and
there's a scenario that's unfolding
one of the groups of 10 is like normal
police officers today and they have the
normal four hours per year of
defensive tactics and combatives
but you have all 10 of them
versus another department
that is training 20 20 of their time is
spent training so
and they've been for a year have been
spent 20 of their time training yeah and
there's a call
some emergency situation
there's a
there's somebody going crazy with a
knife there's you know uh a a domestic
violence scenario where a guy's on pcp
and he's freaking out
and and or you come home to your house
and there's like something bad is
happening at your house
who do you want to show up
is it do you want the 10 people
the 10 police officers that have had
four hours of training each so 40 hours
of training or you want only eight
because two of these guys are are
actually on their training right now
they're not working so you only get
eight but that eight yeah has trained
hundreds of hours over the last year to
prepare for all these different
scenarios there's no doubt who ever
anyone would pick
someone else might say that well that
time could be a lot better to study the
law it could be allotted more for
i don't know marksmanship they're stupid
if they say that it could be a lot more
for for for counseling sessions i mean
the thing is we're talking about human
confrontation and i think how to
de-escalate because in jiu-jitsu it's
not always about me being stronger than
you it's about me finding a way around
yeah and it's also and also that
training is not necessarily
it's not all uh combatives it's not all
shooting you sh you will be taking
de-escalation hey how do you deal with
someone that's oh you can tell they're
clearly angry it's a domestic violence
situation the guy's freaking out what
are you gonna do hey you need to settle
down and it's like no that's not gonna
work out well
yeah you need to hey keep some distance
talk to him you can so you're going to
get trained in all these different
aspects not just training on shooting
and fighting it's training on how to
de-escalate how to get control
how to set things up what psychological
maneuvers can you make to get someone to
calm down like all those things are what
you need to get trained in
so
the fact that i hear the excuse of like
well you need the police out no
untrained police have less value way
less value than trained police not even
close
and you know that was another thing
right as i was having some of those
discussions and arguments while i was in
the seal teams about
hey this system that we're using right
now you guys are trained up in five days
the system that you're talking about
would take years you know three four
five six seven eight nine ten years to
get proficient at
and i i remember i was like occasionally
get a good comeback or whatever i was
like well you're in the teams for 20.
so why not get good at it you know why
would you expect someone to get good in
five days that's something that takes a
lifetime to get good at and by the way
you're in the seal teams for 20 years at
least well i guess you could be for less
than most guys most guys are in it for
four five six seven eight nine 10 11 20
20 25 years let's get good at this thing
so that's the unit training and they
talk about standards and they talk about
making it part of your your physical
training yeah right if you're gonna
train
that's another thing like police
officers
that twenty percent of time that should
be spent training that includes like how
are you getting in shape are you in
shape you want to be in shape if you're
a cop oh my god
you know you see these you see these uh
some of these
videos of police officers
and you're thinking wait a second how is
this person gonna gonna stop anybody
that's remotely athletic even if i just
run away how are you gonna catch anybody
yeah and you know this this whole thing
you know that
we did a podcast on the yuvaldi
situation and it's just yeah it's
terrible what else needs to happen in
america
to realize that we need more training
and by the way
that uvalde situation
the fact that people didn't respond and
and and acted in a cowardly manner is
also part of training
it's also part of training because you
learn like oh if i don't do something
aggressive then i'm gonna get caught
i'm gonna i'm gonna look bad i'm gonna
be bad i'm gonna the culture changes
if you have a culture and i used to see
this with seal platoons if you had a
culture that like you had some of these
platoons coming through and they were
like ready to take on the world and you
throw some scenario at them they were
going on the attack
and that's a culture that that happens
yeah you have another seal platoon where
it's like well we're cautious we have a
zero defect policy we don't want to get
in trouble we don't want to do anything
wrong we don't want to look bad and
that's what happens you see them stack
up on a building i don't want to go do
you want to go i want to go so you have
to you have to
inculcate them with the right culture
where they know hey if you make a
mistake it's okay because you're getting
after it i mean we just did a freaking
podcast about the damn nazis
and part of the nazis culture that they
tried to instill was we'd rather have
you make a bad decision and do something
than not make a decision at all yeah
the worst decision is no decision yes
so the training that i'm talking about
it involves everything and it corrects
all these problems it's getting into
shape getting more attuned to to stress
human confrontation de-escalation
uh how to defend yourself being how do
you feel how to not damage or how to
lessen damage to a suspect yeah i think
it's i think it's awesome overall if you
had that department that i mean i'm not
saying this should be the policy but one
was a michigan some county the sheriff
everyone had to be a blue belt in his in
his department yeah now i'm not saying
that should be
then again but it sounds like we're
we're on the right track yeah we're on
the right track there i'm just saying
like like i think it's a but then again
we're partial because
we we have this great reality called
jiu-jitsu that we're exposed to
but also we're seeing the news
and we're seeing cops
have to do things and get beat up by one
guy and taking two or three people to
take somebody and getting weapons taken
away and it's like awful to see how is
this even happening so it's not look we
might be biased towards jiu jitsu fine
take my bias out of it i'll still tell
you that you better learn how to fight
and you better train and you better
spend time training
choco you've seen at least 10 different
videos so two different i'm talking
brazilian black belt versus um
yeah yeah like like like for instance
like he's mounted on the icon sir yeah
vegas this drunk guy was harassing him
and and even and hall
ryan hall also in some restaurants
no right right oh ryan holland drunk
people and they're just mounted like hey
man calm down they go i'll sue you and
this holding the guy you know he called
the cop you know and the security comes
and no one gets punched and i know this
there aren't cops and the guy doesn't
have a gun i understand what i'm saying
these are black belts which of course
different level but they're holding it
i'm not hurting them yeah and then and
they don't have three homies with with
with batons so by the way you want to
have groups you want to have
team tactics with law enforcement of
course i'm not saying but it is cool if
you have the ability and the opportunity
to well look at that there's also one
from brazil this guy tried to i'm not
saying i think she's just left but she's
this guy tried to uh
i don't know rob take her purse or
something and she's like mounted on the
guy just beat him up this is in brazil
it's a legit black belt you're just
female just the ice cream and he's going
socorro which means help in portuguese
it means helping portuguese and no one's
helping him it's just
it's like chick just mad i just beat the
guy like it was kind of brutal but but
um that is just let's say it's a
grandiose comparison but if you have
that opportunity and that ability it's
pretty cool yeah there we go and and and
it's it's it's heinous to watch this
stuff
on an almost daily basis or i mean at
least once a week you're seeing a video
of of
a cop that's not trained yeah and it had
a bad outcome
and look there's there's all kinds of
cops that are doing the right thing all
the time there's cops that train jiu
jitsu there's cops that are that are
doing things right to the best of their
ability by the way they're investing
their own money yeah and their own time
so that they can be better police
officers
good on them but should you have to make
that sacrifice and by the way what if
you know a guy's got a wife and kids and
he's got a mortgage to pay and all of a
sudden you know it's 148 dollars a month
to train jiu jitsu or it's 165 a month
to train jiu jitsu all of a sudden he's
like
i got to make a choice between you know
getting my kid a new bicycle and
training jiu jitsu uh you know what i'm
gonna sacrifice this month and the next
thing you know they look up in three
years and they're not training anymore
yeah so why not
help the police so that they can help
the community you know do a good job is
our bro ryan with uh bp yeah he has that
yeah what was react now it's called the
board attack the other like the federal
swat team with the board there there's
the guys who killed the uvalde shooter
yeah 100 these guys actually ryan has
these guys i mean they do medical
training i don't know but every day but
they have they have um doing barricades
training you know or their ground i even
did a few you know classes out there and
they don't want to learn like the new
knee lock you know they're doing like
the matters but for for the bird troll
and it's pretty it's pretty cool because
they're not just sitting around uh well
they're going on duty into it but
they're actually training every day this
is pretty cool and that's the way that's
the way
law enforcement should be yeah you
should train
20 of your time if that means you train
you know an hour a day or an hour and a
half or two hours every day or that
means you take one day a week where you
train all day i don't know but figure it
out
because if you're not training you're
not going to be prepared and when you're
not prepared then you overreact when you
overreact that causes problems
and then you get you know innocent
people getting killed
or people that don't deserve to get
killed get killed why because there's a
panic happening it's extreme jackal but
i i'd have an acquaintance that we're
talking he's talking about he was in
afghanistan he wasn't he was in the
marines and he was like no army my back
he was army okay both sides will kill me
for saying that and he was talking about
how they would they would practice
putting ivs in without with night vision
on yeah and like that's you know
well why well in case we have night
vision on we can't see you know and you
know because it's different depth
perception or whatever but he's like
yeah you know that's just something like
okay that makes sense but that sounds
kind of extreme
well why is it extreme
one day you might have to do that yeah
and how much better are you prepared for
if you don't have to have night vision
on well cool yeah and if you happen to
if you happen to roll up on a suspect
and they attack you and they weigh 110
pounds
and they don't know anything cool you
can handle them great but what happens
when they're 220 pounds and they're a
purple belt yep or they wrestled in high
school is it most training for in case
something goes wrong it should be so you
have a jam in your pistol oh well did it
mean you didn't clean your pistol
correctly well it's still going to
happen it's still going to have jams
there's level one two i don't know three
what level that's what's always taught
me uh different ways to clear jam but
it's in case something goes wrong if
something if nothing goes wrong you
actually don't need to drill really
think why did why do i need to drill if
nothing ever goes wrong something's
going to go wrong eventually so that's
i'm just saying jujitsu martial arts
what they're doing in the army i think
is really good because we're getting
ready for in case something bad happens
yeah and all of this
will straighten out your mindset yeah
it will straighten out your mindset
because
if you don't if you're not used to this
stuff
when somebody grabs you and you're not
used to it like somebody grabs me or you
or you like somebody grabs one of us
there's no mental hurdle of any kind to
be prepared for combat in that moment
yeah most people when they get grabbed
they haven't ever been grabbed before
and they have to they have a giant
mental hurdle clear before they can even
respond in any way never mind
appropriately and by the way they're not
going to respond appropriately they're
going to respond badly
so
it's like this has to
change
and like you said i mean i think this is
a lot of the stuff that's in this army
combatives manual is
suitable
for law enforcement
and there's some people that freak out
by the way when you say that oh you want
the cops to be
military paramilitary
no yes actually i want them to be well
trained i want them to be ready for
whatever is going to happen
yeah so
there you go um
let me go through like how to sustain
how to get people sustained where they
can where they can then
keep up their training
and and stay good here's everyday
mission essential task list requiring
use of combative skills a compliant
subject at a traffic control point
suddenly becomes non-compliant
these are just like things to run just
scenarios to run
the battalion indicates that an
intelligent subject must be captured
during the search and seizure mission
the lead man and the search team
encounters hostile opposition and has a
weapons malfunction okay
could that happen yes absolutely
three when turning a corner in a bunker
complex an enemy grabs a soldier's
weapon and pins him against the wall
okay could that happen yes it could
in close quarters an enemy attacks a
soldier under zero illumination could
that happen yes it could
[Music]
these are everyday situations that could
happen
well yeah they could happen in combat
but they could happen in law enforcement
as well
if you're not ready for them in any way
you're not gonna know what to do and
you're gonna fall apart
and then you're gonna end up doing
something stupid in the chocolate you
know i i've uh
i've heard
actually we've talked about this when i
was in puerto rico working with a couple
military guys
that a lot of guys are used to this
these optics like these uh you know
eotech whatever these things on their on
their carbines or their pistols if that
doesn't work one day or it goes out
they're not practiced with open sights
so the thing is like i mean if you rely
upon
that right there specifically that
you don't have that available to you
like you know you're not you're not
keeping yourself up to up to um
up to date upon if something goes wrong
the drilling i think is really good so
if you're if you're exactly caught and
you can't see if i can have someone if i
have a hold of someone i don't need my
eyes that much to be honest you don't
really don't need your eyes
on my five
people compete when they're blind yeah
absolutely there's some strong guys yes
wrong blind guys
ryan job i was training with ryan job
after he was blind and it was like you
know once you make contact with him it's
like it's on
[Music]
talks about you know a bunch of stuff
with live training ground sparring
situational sparring
right that's something that we've been
doing for a long time it's important
soldier a begins with in soldiers b's
guard they spar until sergeant a passes
the guard is swept or submitted
recently again might reset points yeah
that's it
it's very straightforward things but you
could do that with
with every aspect like any of these
scenarios you can run these scenarios
okay it's dark you grab my weapon let's
do it once let's do it twice let's do it
three times let's do it five times what
works what doesn't work
these are like like pieces of the puzzle
that separates each each piece is
different but in the end you put it all
together because it's hard to do the
puzzle unless you see you know what what
the picture of you know what we're going
to make and if you don't understand the
pieces they make the frame with the
corners first and of course and so i
think it's a it's a good way to have
these situational or i call it reset
drills yeah or
timing grade drills it's really good to
have
yeah and they go through
you know everything from like oh how you
spar on the ground how you spar with
takedowns how you do
i guess we call it shoot boxing where
you're like boxing gloves but you're
doing takedowns uh what do they call
that they call it closed locking with
takedowns um
and then you still have to sometimes as
you said earlier if if we only do shoot
boxing
and we never do wrestling by itself or
we never we never advance to where
we're doing
a full sparring
then
we're gonna miss something yeah so you
have to you have to you have to mix it
up to some extent or it can be a problem
this is where it starts talking about
basic ground fighting techniques
basic ground fighting techniques build a
fundamental so all that like we we now
we're getting in this is just talk about
like how to run a program how to set up
a program what the safety protocols are
and then it gets into like the actual
fighting basic ground fighting
techniques build a fundamental
understanding of dominant body positions
and should be one of the primary focuses
before moving on to more advanced
techniques
basic fight strategy when two untrained
fighters meet they instinctively fight
using the universal fight plan they
pummel each other with their fists until
one of them receives enough damage that
they cannot fight back effectively most
forms of martial arts training are
designed to make fighters better at
executing this strategy however this
approach has two drawbacks
one or both fighters are unarmed
progress is solely dependent on the
development of skill
bigger this is actually three drawbacks
bigger stronger and faster fighters have
a natural advantage developing enough
skill to overcome these advantages
requires more time that can be dedicated
to during institutional training well
that's a little bit of a weird thing to
say because we already talked about it
and they already talked about the fact
that it's going to take time
so you can't use that excuse here a
little bit
um
the combatives program uses a more
efficient approach fighting is taught in
the context of strategy the basic fight
basic techniques serve as an edge as an
educating metaphor to teach the basic
fight strategy
fighters learn to defeat an opponent by
controlling the elements of the fight
range angle and level
the number one element of a fight is
range the combatives program has four
phases projectile striking clinching
grappling
this chapter involves the soldiers
provide soldiers with these basic
techniques
at basic levels
against an unarmed enemy according to
circumstances surrounding conflict
fighters can use these techniques to
disable upon or force
the opponent to submit
you know we'll talk about these four
different like they're throwing they're
in the projectiles that's actually
something that's good yeah boss box room
where you say like you could throw a
chair or something yeah and the person
can step for sure so one thing i noticed
which of course great great style
kickboxing the kick with their shins
which that's how i kick but if you have
boot on
if you block shinichin with a shin you
have strong shin you'll find but a boot
hitting your shin
it's an issue bro it's an issue
so savat from france they have these
little like wrestlings with little metal
tips though it's like they're not pointy
but if you block like muay thai and they
have little those little shoes on with
the metal tip out your shin is it's a
problem so interesting based on how
you're dressed the boot you know if you
block your shin a boot kicking your shin
is going to be let's say not a winning
situation for you um so i'm just saying
that essentially we're looking at now
because i'm sure they're not they're
they're thinking about having the
uniform on maybe body armor their uh the
boots
maybe not a boot maybe shoes but
different depends on how you're dressed
that's another thing too however i am on
the side of muay thai i'm on the side of
you know there's even this style in
burma where they use headbutts it's
crazy it's pretty effective by the way
you don't know how to throw a headband
yeah this kind of stuff so i do think
it's good to get the training and the
more you've got when you've got a helmet
on
that's true because then you can
headbutt somebody and it's like no
damage to you at all and they won't like
the results
you know so the way you know but if we
spar with boots and you kick in the
knees you know you're gonna hurt you're
gonna get hurt real fast you probably
can't it's gonna be more dangerous far
more tired you can learn how in case
someone had to do it on how to defend it
you get the training for muay thai with
the tactics and let's say the
open-minded um way that maybe the arms
showing here and you could adapt tactics
for something like that i think it's
good i think it's good to add the
projectiles is actually a good detail
well yeah and by projectiles they also
make sense
yeah
um
here's some here's some like the the
basic concepts
create space
when a winning combat a soldier's
primary goal to be established should be
to establish space between him and his
attacker a soldier must create enough
space to transition to his primary
weapon so so there you go
maintain space when in combat soldiers
may be unable to create enough space
and transition to their primary weapon
if unable to do so they may need to
maintain space to transition to their
secondary weapon
or close the distance gained dominant
body position and finish the fight
so you want to create space you want to
maintain space you might have to close
the distance when training soldiers the
primary goal should be instilling the
courage to close the distance
the willingness to close with the enemy
is a defining characteristic of a
warrior and the ability to do so against
an aggressive opponent is the first step
in using range to control a fight
this is something that i've
talked about so much because you get
that question all the time well is
jiu-jitsu really the best thing for
self-defense and you've heard me give
this explanation a thousand times
if i have space i don't need any
self-defense at all i can get away from
you and run away and that's fine it's
when you grab me that's when we have a
problem that's when i better know jiu
jitsu that's when i better know how to
grapple at least
uh gain so they say close the distance
if you have to if you can't if you can't
create space or you can't maintain space
the next thing is you actually go on on
the attack and you close the distance
you get in close gain dominant position
and then finish the fight
that's their that's the protocol
that they give
and then it gets into ground grappling
ground grappling provides a sound base
and by the way i'm not reading the whole
book obviously uh but
it's skipping ahead to the ground
grappling basic techniques
stand in base with primary weapon
fighting stance opposing grip thumbs
grip wrestler's grip
thumb and thumbless grip
dominant body positions rear mount mount
guard side control
and then it starts giving basic
positions basic moves and it goes
through you know basic finishing moves
rear naked choke cross collar choke from
the mount and guard bent arm bar from
the mount and side control straight arm
bar from the mount straight arm bar from
the guard guillotine choke
blood chokes attack the blood supply to
the brain air choke support attack the
air supply these chokes will take longer
to cause unconsciousness
gives joint locks
tapping procedures that's always good i
think that's
i failed on that one when i when i
when i hurt john dudley my buddy john
dudley
he pushed me no i didn't give him like a
pre-brief okay you know like hey dude i
just assumed
that he would just tap and it may or may
not help because he was also kind of
fired up you know john dudley going
going berserker mode level nine oh yeah
uh and he's a great athlete in like 29
different categories
so when he was going ham
you know
but i didn't give him a good
a good uh brief so make sure if you're
teaching someone you tell them how to
tap
uh then it talks about sweeps and
takedowns and
you know
one thing that's interesting is it
starts giving like how to stand up in
base which we all know but how do you
stand up in base with a weapon
like that's also something to think
about so they address a lot of these
things
that
take a little bit of thought
about how you're going to do it because
you don't want to put down your weapons
so you can stand up no you want to be
able to
you want to be able to stand up while
you're still holding your weapon
fast forward a little bit again you know
they talk about the fighting stance and
the fighting stance allows the soldier
to assume an offensive posture conducive
to attack while still being able to move
and defend himself the fighting stance
is not only perform a platform for
unarmed fighting it can also be used for
various weapons from close range contact
weapons to projectile weapons
just detail man the fighter keeps their
chin tucked the fighter looks just
beneath their eyebrows at the opponent
the fighter uses the lead shoulder to
block the side of the face just squared
away
uh you know procedures and and even the
the whole book the manual's got every
conceivable thing i mean fast forward
here the mount the mount allows a
fighter to strike the opponent with
punches while restricting the opponent's
ability to deliver effective punches
return punches the mount provides the
leverage to attack the opponent's upper
body with trucks and joint attacks it
goes through
in detail
all these different positions and then
you know
uh the guard
and all this stuff is the same stuff we
say a fighter never wants to be under
their opponent the guard enables them to
defend themselves and transition off
their back into a more advantageous
position but yeah that's all what are
you gonna do with a street fight pool
guarded no no one says that
not one person has ever said that in a
serious way they might have joked about
it but no one says pull guard in a fight
guard is made you means you made a
mistake
you messed up that's why you're in guard
a fighter never wants to be under their
opponent
right exactly we all agree with that
the guard allows the bottom fighter to
exercise a certain amount of control
over the range by pushing out or pulling
in his opponent with his hips and legs
yes
so
there you go i mean and it's got
tons of detail in this manual
and and by the way obviously this manual
is unclassified you can find it on the
internet
but it's there and if you want to look
through it go look through it learn
learn some stuff
learn about intermediate ground fighting
techniques
so then it starts talking about the
intermittent fight their intermediate
fight strategy involves adjusting the
basic fight strategy taught in chapter
three to accommodate the unpredictable
and very very nature of operations
though learning basic combative
techniques taught in chapter three
soldiers are instilled with basic fight
strategy the easiest way to impact a
soldier's fighting ability however
soldiers often find themselves in
unpredictable situations that span the
spectrum of operations therefore
soldiers must be prepared to adjust
their fight strategy to fit the
situation rather than making every
situation fit the preferred strategy so
this is telling you
to learn more and be adaptable and try
different scenarios
and now you start talking about
intermediate mount and side control
techniques
posting on the arms posting on the side
larger opponent pins or this is just
getting into more advanced stuff
how to pass the guard attacks from the
mount attacks from the rear out it's
just it just continues to grow
your skill level and eventually gets to
grappling with strikes
right so now
it says here leaders should not make the
mistake of practicing ground fighting
techniques exclusively
striking is an integral part of all
types of fighting grappling with open
and closed fist strikes force the
fighters to ensure that they have
positive control over their opponent's
hands which in turn can prevent the
fighter's opponent from striking them in
the face or using weapons this is what's
cool about eddie bravo's combat jiu
jitsu
right
because there's some positions in jiu
jitsu
they work in jiu jitsu but if you did
them in a fight they're not gonna work
so good when you're getting punched in
the head especially the palm not just a
slap palm strikes like a punch they're
actually not as bone breaking as a punch
with knuckles but they sting more they
hurt their slaps hurt more than oh the
slaps definitely hurt punch they don't
damage your face as much
like oh yeah like like like cut you you
know break your cheekbones things like
that well it's a different kind of pain
but i mean getting punches you can the
palm strike can but that's the slap man
there's no sucking slap slapped on your
chest your back oh yeah the slaps to the
ribs
the slaps of the ribs is like a torture
jockey myself
like remember like if we're having like
one of those days you start pulling the
shirt up and go and bro and then we got
back and forth like we're still bros but
we're sort of like like okay
there's some difference
let's just let's just calm down though
it's not funny there's an escalation
that could occur sometimes
unfortunately for me i'm usually getting
the raw end of that escalation
i have to hope for uh for a piece out
there i remember one time when my kid my
son was probably like
12 maybe
and
we were training and i had a bad ankle
injury speaking of speaking of sarge
sarge
shot a single on me
and
like
i did something or whatever and it
really hurt i was one of the worst
injuries i've had and luckily with sarge
and he like
as it was probably gonna break he like
released and like whatever moved his
weight but my ankles really sprained
and
so i'm rolling a couple days later of
course because that's what we're doing i
had i had like one of that you know the
the the
ankle braces that like lace up is super
tight and they have like a so i had one
of those things on
so i'm rolling with my son and he's like
12.
and you know i like get side control or
something like half guard i'm in half
guard
and i like pull his shirt up a little
bit and
slap him right on the ribs that painful
spot yeah
and you can see he's trying to move and
he can't really you can see it's like
mad right
and then you know whatever a transition
to another position he you know let him
get up on top or whatever
he dives
on a toe hole oh
he dives on a toll on my injured foot
and
well you know quite frankly i probably
should have tapped
i probably should have tapped but
obviously there was no way i was tapping
to my own son
so i like
escaped that
and this is the this is i've told you
this story before so then
then i got across side
and i was i was i was like and i started
i did the uh paper cutter choke the key
yeah
and i go
i said something like hey i'm injured
you idiot
do you want don't don't attack someone
that's injured in their injured area and
trying to hurt them
do you understand
so yes sir no
he didn't answer and he's just looking
at me
and i'm looking at him and i go do you
understand and he's he's still pissed
and i slapped him right so i so i start
applying the choke
and i'm finding it hard and i'm like do
you understand he's still just looking
at me i'm like okay i'm gonna kill him
i'm like okay test of wills he's gonna
have to die that's it so i start you
know you know how that paper cutter
choke you go down then you start going
out i was down and now i'm going out
and he's starting to turn red and purple
and find he's like understand i was like
what you think of that and i was like
okay and then we just kept trading you
know
you had that coming to you by the way oh
i definitely had it coming to me
although
yeah i had to come to me there's a
debate of principle for sure but
you had it coming to you
wait what
why yeah during the slap thing that's
not the thing that's that thing even
though the slap thing is still done in
in fun right there's still a level of
fun to it there's no fun about trying to
hurt someone that's injured yeah
yeah
but the argument could be made hey look
i'm not your son i'm not you so i don't
know but
maybe some of us didn't sign up for that
fun that day you see insane
that's good that it's fun for you it
really is you know congratulations you
know what though you gotta learn to
control those emotions a little bit it's
part of the process it's part of the
process
remember remember when um when you were
back
at city boxing came back from wherever
you had like tom you had grady mac you
had you know you got all these guys in
the mat like 10 seals you had one marine
who was who was the the fourth weekend
yeah yeah yeah and you got training i
was i was slapping them like because
they were down with it because they were
getting ready for like deployment it was
like and i was talking smack to them i'm
like um
uh request permission to go go back to
base mission mission not accomplished i
know
say it
mission scrubbed request permission
anyways that was a game but then again
there was some fired up guys and it was
like the game so the average person i
wouldn't you know just cross the body
but the sun yeah injured foot understood
roots so what's your what's your
assessment echo says i'm wrong
um it's kind of mutual like like like
you and i we do it because we think it's
funny it's statistically funny by the
way jacqueline has his days he makes me
feel kind of ashamed sometimes
but it's a mutual thing it's just
different i don't know why um i've done
it for such a long time we've always
trained that way we've always trained
that way for sure risk whatever yeah you
know how okay so this is i think this is
true so you know rattlesnakes right when
they're like not full grown when they
bite they say they're kind of dangerous
right because they can't control their
venom
so consider your 12 year old kid right
you're like okay we're going we're going
street level or whatever right because
there's such thing as street rules
so okay we're going straight rules and
that's what i would say the slap is i
mean it's usually mutual and kind of
understood
in this way but someone might
misunderstood it and like go hand back
like really hard exactly right yeah you
don't just do it to anybody so yeah yeah
i'm like like a random person involved
yeah your friend or your enemy your
friend
rib slap your your enemy that's sort of
like dumb move right that's this is just
like you know general friendly
harassment yes yeah friendly harassment
exactly right so but the reason you
don't do it to like a stranger or
something it's like you don't know their
reaction yeah they don't they don't
they're not under that element of
control that your friends are now 12
year old kid who's to say where he's at
mentally it's insane
apparently he's in a vengeance he's like
a little rattlesnake where he's like
okay we're taking it to that level we'll
take it to like he don't know though he
don't know what that means as far as the
translation to what he can do you know
so he's just going for what's he going
for
jumping on that toe hold yeah yeah okay
crank it
like i said frankie you had that coming
to you sir
yeah i don't know man
i guess i i know i see you you're
probably right man yeah
i told you me that escalation
i guess you know what it is part of it
is for me this was just like
a way to make things more fun yeah
i would actually agree with that you
know like
dean
like there's a certain level of if dean
and i get in that zone there's a certain
level of it's just a way to make it a
little bit more fun a little bit more
consequences yeah
the the other day training charcoal like
i was having a good day and um i'm like
neon we call it park bench river park
bench yeah
you can't move and i'm like all right
sir straighten your legs like
i'm trying to make him like lie against
the wall straight but he won't let me do
it
so
so you're pinning just like your back's
on the wall you're on your side and
someone's shin is in your face in your
stomach you're just like [__] man it's
called park bench
it's worse than you on stomach it's a
very demoralizing uh situation jocko did
it back to me of course but but yeah it
just makes it fun you know and it looks
real bad too yeah it looks pretty bad
yeah
when you're in the bottom you're like
you feel you feel like i don't know why
i'm here bro
i made several mistakes too yeah
for anyone not not aware told is
basically grabbing like your toe doing
that but for your toe and it's actually
your arm is more flexible than your than
your ankle your knees so it's actually
it can be a damaging move for anyone
wondering what a toe is grabbing the toe
yeah twisting the ankle therefore the
knee as well yeah for the record uh
i don't think necessarily that you were
in the wrong in fact i think that your
son was kind of technically in the wrong
but a little rattlesnake you can't
expect him to control he to know the
line all definitely it was tactical who
was strategical which one was tactical
and strategically was that a strategic
strategic versus tactical strategically
he's trying to make him into a tougher
better fighter yeah
tactically yeah was it good
tactically maybe i shouldn't have let
him out
teach him a long-lasting lesson imagine
imagine that the thing that i i will say
is like
it surprised me right it surprised me
that he dove on the toe hold yeah
because he he had the weird combination
of dean lister and jeff glover game huh
you know because he
he would train with dean lister and jeff
glover these weird heel hooks and like
toe holds and then he's like doing weird
flexible things so anyways you gotta
watch out for that stuff there is this
little snake where i kind of went over
this with you real briefly one time in
our whole life where
okay so and dean you could probably
understand this dude okay let's say we
roll right and i in my mind i just know
i believe like you're just so much
better than me and we're rolling i'm
just trying to you know but at the end
of the day i know like you're just so
much better than me i'm 12 years old or
a me and you're you or whatever right
let's say okay you tapped me out dean
you tapped me out real quick and then
i'm like oh man cool
and then i like act like i'm gonna walk
away and then i jump on your back and we
start rolling again right just kind of
like half joking but we still go and
roll whatever you kind of concede a
little bit where it's like okay i see
what's going on like we're in a real
training scenario we wouldn't do that
right so he's going to escalate yeah and
he can escalate he can figure it but i'm
saying what you did was an escalation by
the way yes but it's half joking yeah
you see him saying it's like yeah
what's that over there and then you jump
right right yes yes
the time yeah yeah yeah exactly right so
this yeah i'm now seeing there's a
there's a like a legitimate
like you escalated if you just jump to
someone's back even though you quote
unquote are joking you still got their
back and now you're trying to choke them
what is that's exactly what he said dude
and he was like you indicate i forget
your words but you indicated that like
like don't do that like we're not trying
like that you did it to me for real yeah
oh yeah bro long time ago used to always
do that kind of stuff to you and then i
was like hey bro
come on what did i say did i say
something that's weird and when we
actually talked about it you're like
you're you i forget your exact words but
you weren't down for that all right it's
like it's not that bad
but you found me like you call me out
put it this way
i was surprised because it's not like
you did anything you know it's not like
you said hey don't you know don't do
that or nothing because you never said
anything like that but when you indicate
oh yeah you're not down for that i
understood but you have to understand i
wouldn't do that if we had a real
competition it was like you're so much
better than me so yeah i'm gonna jump on
your back and i still don't expect to
get the better you even if i jump on
your back because you're so it's like
that attitude i think so that could have
been what your son had in his mind a
little bit too though
go for it yeah like i i mean obviously
dean's not going to do that
dean will do that
hell yeah no no no
oh there you go there's some protocols
there's some etiquette right sometimes
it gets violated sometimes it's grayers
i may i agree i'm probably wrong kid's
12 should be nicer should have been a
nicer uh nicer dad sorry about that yeah
kid
yeah we talked about grappling with
strikes and all that and it goes through
some of those things and then it gets
into like advanced ground fighting
techniques and north-south escapes and
north-south like all those things
chain attacks and how everything's
connected so so leg attacks dean lester
this section covers the advanced leg
attacks these techniques are taught as a
way to change the
fighter's position into a submission
although the techniques are advanced
they still present the same amount of
hazard as a tax learned at lower levels
so we got some
ideas behind that as well
reading
and opponents moves i mean this is just
a thorough
a very thorough
book
about
combatives um
and they just did a good great job with
it and
a lot of the theories that are in here
just cover
what we know and they do it in a very
professional way yeah in a very thorough
way and and the last thing that it talks
about is competition
and
[Music]
the spirit of competition the
competition principles you know um that
he says this is important two things
we'll finish with this combatives
techniques are too dangerous for
competition
although many techniques are too
dangerous for live competition many
benefits can be gained by competing even
when using a limited set of techniques
so there are some things that are too
dangerous
and then it says risks of competition
outweigh the benefits many programs have
failed because there was no motivation
to train competitions are a useful tool
to motivate both soldiers and unit
leaders to emphasize combatives training
so
competition
very important
and
there you have it um
like i said great document
um
outstanding job by the army for moving
in that direction absolutely incredible
yeah yeah and and the marine corps has
the mcmap when we go through that
martial arts program the i know special
operations well i know in the seal teams
we moved in that direction as well
uh around the same
actually i don't know if i don't know
time wise but we we all end up in the
same place
and
you know the theory here is like you
gotta compete you gotta learn you gotta
test you gotta get better you know this
you know saying keep it real
yeah you ever say that
echo do you ever say hey keep it real i
say it from time to time yes sir do you
ever say keep it real
high school maybe i actually i actually
say keep it real like almost and i kind
of just throw it out there like if i'm
you know someone goes hey what's up i'll
be like oh you're keeping it real like
that you know kind of just whatever sure
kind of a throwaway comment sure
but i was thinking about it it's
actually a good attitude to have
with combatives with fighting with life
keep it real
and that's what i think this does keep
it real don't allow for the lies
the lies
you got to test you got to learn you got
to adapt you got to improve then you got
to re-test and you can do that with
fighting and you can do that with
everything
in life and that's how we become better
fighters and that's how we become
better people yeah
so that's my recommendation man
that's true train get out there
huh
anything else on combatives dean lisch
combatives
well we're looking at that fine balance
of training some you could train you
could replicate over and over without
getting
really injured or hurt
um
with also
including some realism as far as getting
ready for the actual threat that you
will face such as by the way if you
grapple on concrete all the time um it's
going to suck now you want to be aware
for instance one time actually i fell uh
for some reason
on the concrete with my my hand and
broke my hand uh because we have mats
so i actually i know how to fight if
ethanol mats but i i made a mistake i
should open my hands at the right time
these are things i have to keep in mind
but then again you need you want to
train on mats right so so why not why
not always train on concrete well
because your knees will be jacked up you
hurt your head you're going to break
your elbow eventually
but um you want to be aware of that
one thing it was it was one of sergeant
knows him and all the guys in puerto
rico when i was there for for a few
weeks after the hurricanes working we're
just delivering water that's all um
one guy and you probably know him i
don't know his name the story is the guy
was a x
tier one whatever i don't know seal i
think seal became a cop but he was
ranked top ten in the world with
shooting but where your hands are here
and you reach it's a quick draw the
guy's like ranked top ten in the world
is at the quick draw where your hands
are above eddie so he he got stuck up
like he was off duty someone actually
pulled a gun on him he went like this
he because he's so trained to do that he
still won killed he drew on the draw i
mean the guy was i mean that's the
fastest guy he's still yeah it's
considered like you're not supposed to
draw someone's already you know
considered dumb this guy is too fast so
so he actually went from here and still
eliminate you know survive from the guy
i don't think he he made it the guy with
the loaded gun
trying to rob him but the thing is that
training of him being so fast is good
but
he didn't need to do this
he's trained so much did you shoot from
here he's still one but that's a wasted
movement think about that so he still
won so that right there that kind of
training i think for quick draw is good
but then again don't put your hands up
here maybe that would actually play it
into the whole yeah okay he's complying
yeah maybe it's actually good but i'm
saying it's always they were saying how
he still survived because he was trained
so so that was just uh and you know the
guy i don't know his name but that was
sergeant all the guys in there like it's
a tight community so i think it it's
good to have that middle ground we're
looking for the middle ground you want
to replicate things you want to be able
to do in a relatively safe environment
but always be be prepared for what is
going to happen potentially
that's why i like what the army is doing
it's a guideline there's some
flexibility there i think of course the
lego locks
get to the other story about the russian
you know actually
the first time i learned leg locks
before choke holds in at this seminar
he's got a nikolai battering he was the
soviet champion of [__]
old tatar was there other russians were
teaching and they were saying like
the reason they prefer lake walk is
because
um
back in russia i'm with my wife she's
very attractive and i go to a bar a
strange man grabs her inappropriately
i'm very upset i break his arm now he
goes the vehicle gets kalashnikov comes
back and did
i'm like bro i'm 18 years old man
like but imagine another scenario the
guy grabs my girl very inappropriately i
break his leg takes a long time to go
via kalashnikov
there's always some kind of use for me
i'm like it makes sense you know
i'm already with wife at home sleeping
in bed
i was actually supposed to legs before
chokes believe it or not so yeah it's
all good to have open mind well uh but
chokes are part of [__] as well um
combat [__] in usa illegal because this
is back in stephen cigal days they
thought chokehold you die you know like
you know so in sport [__] sport [__]
well i think combat slumber was not
illegal but back then it was um you
could do a straight arm lock not even
you can do a kimura ensemble just also
ensemble straight kneeling if you have
an arm lock and i stand on my feet it's
illegal submission now restarting your
feet so that's that's an escape from a
submission just stand on your feet if i
stand i'm i have nothing but my my feet
are the only thing person around stop
all submissions are illegal so
yeah yeah
at some point they probably had some
reason for that like probably like if i
pick you up and now i could drop you on
your head yeah so therefore it's not
it's not gonna work anymore when we
actually know you let that evolve a
little bit further
and now i'm going to when you start to
pick me up i'm going to grab your
individual and i'll hold on and keep you
down and so you need to let things
evolve naturally yeah rules don't help
that usually i agree i agree yeah i won
two-time national champion of samba was
like 19. and the third time i was going
to get third i was going to be a
three-time but then i got in the finals
and the guy he went my day everybody
stood up so he means they give up he's a
judo guy oh he got his arm
that's illegal submission um
and my feet will cross around the neck
they go it was almost chocolate minus
one so i got him one minus one to zero
so i lost so i took second place one
year unfortunately but that's okay so
he's almost a good sport time champ and
then one time yeah samba is a tough
sport it's good
[Music]
yeah i mean look at fedor
fedor was a was a
[__] champion yeah combat zombo so was
khabib you know yeah tough
yeah would you say khabib is more of a
wrestler yeah yeah but he's he's done
judo [__] but yeah he's his style is
very much he's very suited for for
nougie yeah just smashing people yeah
smashing
all right on awesome all right well
appreciate everyone for listening thank
you can i mention something real fast
anyone anyone looking to
august 789 costa rica we're running a
jiu jitsu camp and uh if it was on
instagram interested in training it's
for all all skill levels
uh ron from uh bjj hero bjj retreats
is a good guy to contact if he was
interested in high level jiu jitsu for
three or four days in beautiful costa
rica work in your spanish
your tan and your leg locks
hit it up right hero camps in costa rica
hopefully i'll see you all there and you
can post it on your instagram as well
yeah so that way people when they hear
this they can follow the link or
whatever absolutely and go there and
check that out i mean that sounds like a
rough deal going to costa rica and doing
jiu jitsu how long is it it's well it's
three with four days four days yeah
that sounds like a good time no no what
is it
august 7 8 9 so so everyone rides the 6
7 8 9 and the 10th is like it's like a
free day so it's like 40 years long
awesome yeah check that out if you want
to go learn some jiu jitsu from the
boogie man the boogeyman yeah yeah the
boogie man check it out thanks for
supporting the podcast go to
jacofuel.com
if you want to get some of these drinks
by the way
which are freaking good to go they taste
delicious
used to be couldn't say that well some
of us could yeah they're gonna be like
oh they taste good now different
different ball game yeah you're
reformulated to perfection i think
um
yeah so so get yourself some of that
that's uh you know the the energy drink
thing
the reason we made them look i was on
deployment we used to drink other brands
of energy drinks that were filled with
sugar you're doing too many of those
things oh yeah yeah for sure and you
feel awful it's even worse not worse
than drinking but i mean it's not it's
it's horrible for you that's bad and so
that's what happened on deployment it
would be like that and that's why i
wouldn't at jocko fuel
you know
it was like hey do you
brian asked me like do you want to do an
energy drink and i was like hey
i would only want to do that if it was
possible to make them like actually good
for you yeah and then he was like let me
come up with a formula just start with
your cranberry white tea is that how it
started yeah that's how it started
chocolate is white cream organic
pomegranate white tea what did you say
chai is that what we're saying
cherry white cherries
well pomegranate it's not as obvious
okay so i get it thank you
yeah but if there is a benefit there's
times when you need energy yeah so you
might get it and you might as well not
have a bunch of sugar in there and have
an overload of caffeine that makes you
jittery and crazy just get something
that's smooth good clean energy good for
you that's a jocko discipline go
jockofield.com you can get it at wawa
you get a vitamin shop
you can get it at heb down in texas a
month we're we're spreading i need to co
i need to get a list remind me i got to
get a list of all the places you can get
jackal fuel
so there you go you have demand for it
in brazil now
i know
we got it we got it down in australia
too oh yeah uh there's we have a
distributor down there in australia so
that's going forward
so yeah we're spreading because it's
good
the mulk is good
the joint warfare is good the super
krill's got so it's all good
and that's what people
kind of know now like we're making the
good stuff we're making the goods
get yourself some of that originusa.com
making geez jiu-jitsu geez you want to
train that jiu-jitsu yeah you want to
train that jiu-jitsu
because it's going to make your all your
game better
guinogi if you do get you're going to
get better
i think your defense gets better when
you wear because you're stuck more
because you're stuck more yeah your
offense gets better when you don't have
a guillotine because you have to do it
really
you have to keep advancing more with
with uh with no gi because people slip
out easier yeah
you should get a key that's made in
america not by slave labor but by made
by hardworking americans that's my
recommendation
originusa.com we got some hunt gear on
the way actually what's today i should
be hitting my though i should be getting
some the first like production stuff
coming soon choco can you make a key
that's just like sandpaper like a
sandpaper ghee
i want to get really good i was really
good at escaping actually no
because you're not slipping on that the
origin keys are so comfortable yeah yeah
they're so good they're a different
thing
they're they're we are spoiled now yeah
they are spoiled my first jiu-jitsu guys
were like bloody nasty bloody awful to
wear yeah so don't do that go to
originusa.com get yourself some jeans
boots hunt gear jiu jitsu gear
we got it we got you covered made in
america all of it it's true good stuff
to the bone speaking of apparel jock was
a store as well it's called jocko store
dean lister has his own shirt yeah yeah
we're gonna have this is it out is it
live it's been live
actually we haven't really this one that
says foot yet foot okay so so it's a
takeoff on the good shirt shut up
you were like what the [__]
it started off with the good shirt which
had my head on it
and then the echo shirt which said dang
sure which had your head on it which i
designed
and then who designed your shirt
well i came up with just i did it like
in 20 minutes just as a joke i wore it
to the pocket and he was like oh more
likes
so if you don't know dean lister is uh
notorious and famous for changing
this the the realm of jiu jitsu by
attacking the feet and the legs and the
knees
and so he made a shirt with his head on
it we made a shirt with his head on it
and instead of saying good
this is foot okay
it actually came out really really good
yeah um also yeah some news some new
stuff on there this one equals freedom
standard issue standard issue many color
ways
look at you with the big words i feel
like i'm talking to pete roberts over
here talking about colorways and whatnot
yeah yeah hey you taught me so yeah did
i actually teach you that you knew that
it sounded familiar but you're the one
who said colorways and explained it i
was like okay
i might have heard it before
i've never used it until just now that's
that's really dipping your toes into the
fashion industry when you start saying
colorways
i think can be used to describe like uh
uh
like cars or like like
you know anything anything
anything that could be made in multiple
colors i believe they the in the
industry they use the term colorways
like sneakers sneakers i think that's
how i know it
from sneakers someone's talking to a
sneaker professional who was like yeah
we got to offer these different
colorways
i said okay little combos of colors
there you go yeah well there you go we
got colorways but anyway yes we call it
the standard issue discipline equals
freedom shirt it's good it's new
i didn't blow it up yet but you know all
right so you can check that out also we
got the shirt locker which is a
subscription situation if you didn't
know um you know new designs every every
month you get a new shirt a new design a
little bit more uh creative that's what
i'm not at right now mm-hmm thank you
for haven't gotten very creative on your
creative descriptions no not creative
yet so why because all the creativity
goes into the designs you see what i'm
saying not the descriptions of the
snacks it'd be like a meta description
either way they're good uh great
feedback on that so check that out at
jacques jacquelinestore.com
all right thanks everybody subscribe to
the podcast go to jackonground.com
hear some underground podcasts
check out youtube where i'm the
assistant director one of the best
apparently one of the best out there you
know the best assistant director just
keeping echo charles tight on stuff
psychological warfare flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer making cool stuff to hang
on your walls i've written a bunch of
books read them if you want
echelon front
echelonfront.com
leadership consultancy that's what we do
we solve
problems through leadership
so if you want help inside your
organization go to echelonfront.com for
details next up is atlanta
october 12th through the 14th the muster
it's going to sell out they all do
so we'll see you there also we have an
online training academy just like jiu
jitsu you're not going to get you're not
going to get good at fighting
in one day or one week you've got to do
it all the time that's why we made the
academy extreme ownership academy
extreme ownership.com come and learn how
to lead and live
that's what it's going to do for you and
if you want to help out service members
active and retired their families gold
star families check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization
it does outstanding work supporting
mama all warriors yup
and if you want to help her out or you
want to get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
also check out micah micah fink he's got
heroes and horses.org just got out of
the field i think today
a bunch of dudes been out in the field
for 41 days riding horses sitting in
cold water eating raw meat
just getting back
back to it
and
so check that one out and if you want to
check out dean
dean's on the gram on the instagram he's
at dean lister bjj
that's right i cannot
be held accountable for some of the
things that he posts
[Music]
some drama you go to some dark places in
weird times so
you wake up in the morning and and
there's a post from dean lister at three
o'clock in the morning
hey
uh what's that be advised dude right be
advised
it's random you might be offended
you might be disgusted very possible
yeah
man he sent me one the other day was
that a post from instagram the guy
getting cut the neck oh that was it was
sent it was sent to me yeah i mean it
was like a horrible scene
of a guy
there's like it looks like your typical
kind of couple drunk do like three four
drunk guys you know gonna fight another
three or four drunk guys and they're
kind of talking smack to each other and
then one of the guys like pulls out a
knife in kind of that kind of like way
like oh i've got a knife out you better
back off and the other guy's sort of
like do well you wouldn't do anything
anyways and it just sort of seems like
this kind of innocent it's crazy kind of
i mean as innocent as it could be
pulling out a knife he was that innocent
that's all it is right i'm saying as in
it didn't look like the intent was we're
about to murder somebody
and the one one dude that doesn't have a
knife comes kind of like walking over
like oh what are you gonna do cut me
like with that kind of look on his face
but but not expecting anything to happen
and in a
millisecond
in a millisecond the dude like swings at
him with a knife and cuts his throat and
the dude is dead in ten seconds he
passes off he passes out in five seconds
and he's probably dead another
so
another reason don't get in street
fights
don't get in street fights they're
stupid you get stabbed in the neck you
could break your hand whatever anything
in between
so don't do that but if you want to
check out dean lister on instagram there
he is deanlisterbjj
on the twitter on the gram on facebook
i'm on there as well echoes on there
echo's adequate charles i'm at jocko one
link watch out for the algorithm by the
way because that thing is going to grab
you is going to waste an hour of your
day
you're going to take an hour from you
imagine that a monster that came in
every day and took an hour from you or
two hours from you can't get it back
that's the algorithm monster it's gonna
get you so that's it
uh thanks to all the soldiers sailors
airmen and marines who continue to find
ways to fight better in every respect
thanks again to matt larson for driving
this initiative in the army i know
there's like i said i know i'm sure
there's a bunch of other people that
helped out
i know that he was leading the charge so
salute to him
and
[Music]
the rest of the military personnel that
are out there putting these skills to
the test on the battlefields thanks for
what you do also thanks to police and
law enforcement
do what you can to get out there and
train
you need it
we need it
also firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service all the first
responders
thank you for keeping us safe here in
our own country
and to everyone out there
go train
train whatever you can train wrestling
train boxing jiu jitsu muay thai train
judo and [__] and train with guns and
knives and bow and arrow and test and
learn and adjust and get better and it
will make you better in every aspect of
life just go
train
and until next time this is dean and
echo and jocko
out